this is Jacob podcast number 387 with
Echo Charles and me Jocko willink good
evening Echo good evening
combatives
the art of hand-to-hand combat Bridges
the gap between physical training and
tactics
the products of a good physical training
plan strength endurance and flexibility
must be directed toward the mission and
soldiers must be prepared to use
different levels of force in an
environment where the intensity of a
conflict changes quickly
many military operations such as
peacekeeping missions or non-combatant
evacuation May restrict the use of least
lethal Force
combatives training prepares the soldier
to use the appropriate amount of force
for any situation
combatives training includes arduous
physical training that is mentally
demanding and Carries over to other
military Pursuits this training produces
soldiers who
understand controlled aggression and
remain focused while under duress
possess the skills requisite to the
mission at all levels in the spectrum of
force
have the attributes that make up the
warrior ethos
personal courage self-confidence
self-discipline
and Esprit de corps
and that right there is a quote from the
U.S Army's
technical circular
tc3tac-25.150 combatives
and the Army has made
huge advancements in the past several
decades in their combatives capability
and ability
the Incorporated elements of grappling
and striking and weapons into a
comprehensive system
that
has become a solid foundation for
soldiers that are in any military
occupation
but as the manual States combatives
doesn't only help soldiers with
hand-to-hand combat
it helps with improving all their
attributes as soldiers and as human
beings
and it's an honor to have one of those
soldiers with us here tonight who has
led at all levels as an officer
who not only trains and combatives but
helped establish the combatives program
in the army
his name is General Michael farader he's
a retired army General he served in
Somalia he served in Iraq
he's a black belt in Brazilian Jiu Jitsu
and he's here to share his experiences
and Lessons Learned with us General
thank you for joining us it's my
pleasure good to see you I always have a
good time diving into the history of
combatives in the Army in the Marine
Corps even the single teams has a little
history of combatives we have an old I
have an old uh Field Manual from years
and years ago and it's pretty neat to
see and there's been some
some vast improvements in combatives
over the years I'm sure we'll get into
that but uh I always like to start at
the beginning let's let's talk about
where you came from what made you you
well I came uh
grew up in an Army Family my dad joined
the army during World War II at the
beginning of World War II he's a private
he went officer candidate School
and uh served in the Pacific he was put
in for Medal of Honor they received a
distinguished service cross
uh and as he raised my brothers and
sisters he always told us you got to
take care of the men you got to take
care of your troops and then things will
work out for you and so also being an
officer candidate we had to roll our
socks and put them in the drawer and
smiles facing up and answer the phone
you know Colonel frerger's quarters
Mikey speaking this line is unsecured
you know back in the 60s so so how long
did your dad stay in for 27 years you're
tired as a colonel yeah and were you
just old school moving all the time
growing up yeah we we moved uh I'm I
lived in 18 houses by the time I was 18
years old
and then raised a family and probably
moved them just as many times
and this we just came out a month of the
military child and
um there's a lot of Truth to the
resiliency and flexibility and
adaptability of military kids and their
ability to start over you know my mom
used to throw us out in the yard and say
go explore find out who lives in this
neighborhood see where the other kids
are
so your dad was put in for the Medal of
Honor and ends up getting uh the
distinguished service cross what what
did you growing up what did that mean to
you what did you know about what
happened or do you know did you did you
do you have the citation hanging on the
wall did you hear the story from him
from his buddies or what was at it like
that's pretty amazing yeah that you know
that generation my dad had I think a
silver star a couple bronze Stars a
couple purple hearts and they were in
the garage on the wall they didn't have
an I I love me room like like my
generation right so
um but I went back to Guadalcanal with
him when I came out of Ranger company
command in 1989 and we walked his
battlefields and we went and dug out
canoes with with Islanders and we walked
up on you know we saw where chesty
puller and the Marines went and red
Beach and then Inland and then all the
way up to almost to New Caledonia it was
amazing so your dad did like the full
Pacific Campaign he did yeah
I mean talk about casting a shadow you
must have always felt I mean to this day
I mean how do you ever feel like uh you
know when your dad's that guy that's
amazing well you don't want to
disappoint them you could take a
whooping but but if you get the d word
you know I'm just warning then that that
just kills you so he was a great athlete
um he played uh before the NBA he played
professional basketball and he played up
to AAA baseball he came out of World War
II went back to play baseball and you'd
lost a lot of steps and a lot of speed
and so he went back in the Army and uh
and then continued on and then you go to
Korea as well uh he did not fight in
Korea he went uh like probably in 53 or
54 58 about 58 yeah I was always
interested in that part of Dick Winter's
book where dick Winters you know fought
World War II a little entire European
campaign they recall him for for Korea
he gets to I think it was San Francisco
they're about to get on the boat and
they said hey anyone that was that
fought in World War II you don't have to
go and he goes cool I'm out he he had
enough combat you know he's done and he
said go back to my Farm in Pennsylvania
amazing and um so so you're growing up
you're going to different schools all
the time what what schools were or sorry
what sports were you playing I played
baseball and basketball were you any
good I was pretty good were you
disappointing your dad the whole time no
no
I I did not
you know going back to that military uh
child different different kids you know
could could get after better than others
my older brother didn't like it and he
didn't play sports and and he you know
he would get the d word more than than
me but uh
um we moved to Germany so and we lived
in Heidelberg and then Berlin so you
know
um a lot of my deeper thoughts about
where American strength and power and
the investment in our our young men and
women
you know when when we have the footprint
in Berlin the Russians did not
you know and so now in the Middle East
when we get sent over there there's
there's some validity to when we're
there then the Persians are not and so
um pretty you know never a couple
incidents when everyone mounted up on
the Berlin Wall you know machine guns
and tanks up and uh so it kind of gives
you as a 12 13 14 year old a good taste
of there's a real world out here and so
you you know if you're going to do
something do something that makes a
difference and be ready when it's time
so how old were you when you decided you
were probably going to go into the army
it was pretty funny because because here
I'm in San Diego and uh we retired my
dad retired and we went up to Lake Tahoe
for a couple years and then saw my high
school and then my last year was down in
Monterey and uh at the in Pebble Beach
at the school
and so I applied to West Point and did
not get in and applied to uh ROTC and
back then if you got an ROTC scholarship
every school that has ROTC rights here
so I I felt like you know Tom Brady
everyone wanted me
and so I said to him my Dad hey Dad uh
University of California Santa Barbara I
can play baseball down there there's all
kinds of you know good looking girls
down there
and he said hey I want you to take a
look at this school in Charleston South
Carolina to Charleston yeah it's a
military school I said that I got
shoulder length hair man I'm playing
baseball
he said you need to take a look at this
and so I I said no I'm gonna go to UCSB
and he said take a look at it again and
so didn't want to disappoint him right
and so and I said you know I loved it in
fact when I was in Berlin
back then in Vietnam if you were a great
athlete you you were playing on the
commanding generals football full pad
football Above the Rim basketball and
fast pitch baseball and so I would talk
to these 18 19 20 year old guys and say
really you don't ever put a uniform
on except for sports and I said Dad I
want to join the Army I want to do that
so that was kind of in the back of my
head
knowing that that really wouldn't be
that way though a lot of people who've
known me for the 35 years that I served
to think that that's probably what I did
anyways a lot of time in the gym and a
lot of time on the playing fields but uh
so I said okay I'll go to this military
school for one year if I you know if it
works out fine so what year what year
did was it that you graduated high
school 75 75. so you had long hair and
your dad was okay with that he was not
laughs
uh what kind of music were you listening
to just like the typical 70s rock yeah
probably Beach Boys and Eagles and and
uh Doobie Brothers uh-huh and and he
convinces you to give one year shot at
the Citadel yeah did you have any when
you went there you know a lot of times
young men are impressed by the whole the
uniforms and the discipline and they get
a little bit excited about that thing
did you have any of that or were you
just doing it to gratify the old man
you know there's a lot of physical uh
challenge there too so I enjoyed you
know you know the running and the
obstacle courses and and uh working out
and then some Elite you know drill teams
or other kind of teams trying out for
those things
um but what what's funny is
um two years later my brother goes to
University of California Santa Barbara
oh yeah I'm fixing a little brother so
but uh
um the president of the Citadel was a
guy named cygneous Lieutenant General
retired and he had been the Commanding
General in Berlin so they they had me
booked you know six years earlier that I
was going to end up going to that school
dang yeah and it it worked out pretty
good so you show up there they shave
your head the whole nine yards yeah at
the end of the first day I'm rubbing a
shaved head think and Dad won Mike zero
let's see where this goes from here were
you uh you know I was talking to people
about the Shaka boot camp and it's did
you get that little shock of saying what
the hell am I doing here not really you
were down you were ready yeah and then
then you you go what are you studying
when you're in at the Citadel
studied business and uh
you know mostly the management
leadership management side of it it
interested me in accounting
I didn't like not so much and what about
sports are you playing any sports ended
up um trying out for the baseball team
and got a call back and that was the
first day we were allowed to go downtown
Charleston
so this is where you know the young
women were like five for every Cadet and
so I saw this workout for the baseball
career yeah it became a huge intramural
player so they had Sports all you know
all year round so I got to you know
still get the book and
and you had a good experience overall at
the Citadel now yeah real good then uh
what year did you get commissioned 79
and did you so when you're getting
commissioned in 1979
what this is Jimmy Carter's president
the what's what's the outlook on the
military as you're going in it's low
funding
probably recruiting trouble or I guess
recruiting that might not have been too
bad because the economy was bad
um post Vietnam
um
all the good ncos and good officers many
many had left service they they've seen
what combat is like you said about the
winners and uh a lot so in the first
couple years most of the ncos that I had
were
alcoholics and it's all volunteer Force
just started and
um
so that and the
um I ended up at a mechanized infantry
in Fort Riley Kansas and the Army back
then had tiered Readiness and so if you
know 96 days get on a train go to
Germany but if you're in the 82nd so you
were level four so you're unfunded
um we had a rifle company with three
platoons authorized but only men for two
platoons so it was it's pretty bad until
President Reagan came in and and really
uh you know resourced us a couple big
things happen in those first six years
when you when you got commissioned you
go straight to uh to go to the Infantry
officers basic course is that what is
that what the pipeline was it was yeah
and how long was that school uh 14 weeks
are you feeling like you got a good
education in that I mean I had uh I had
James Webb on here who was in the Marine
Corps Navy cross recipient and he was
went to the basic school went to the
Marine Corps infantry School infantry
leader School
got on had 12 days of leave got on a
plane went to Vietnam went out they
walked him out into the Middle Field
pointed up original and said that
there's your platoon he walked up there
he said who am I relieving a sergeant
said I've been the platoon Commander for
the last whatever it was our other
platoon Commander got wounded or killed
you're in charge and that night they got
a big gun fight and he was calling in
air support
and I said were you ready for that
and he he said yes so they at that time
you know in the middle of the Vietnam
War they the Marine Corps was squared
away at getting those guys ready you
know I've often looked at some of the
training that I went through in the 90s
and thankfully we didn't get thrown into
war because we wouldn't have been ready
for it how did you feel that that course
prepared you
then
I think we would all say it prepared us
to do a squad Leader's job
not command a platoon and combat yeah
and uh and that was going to be taught
when you got to your first unit and if
you had a squared away Captain you know
O3 then it was taught and if you didn't
um your sergeants would probably bring
you along if you're smart enough as an
officer to listen
then that's what happened to me like my
captain was was horrible
you show up your Captain's honorable so
now it's on the ncos that are going to
get you trained up we just kind of said
hey we're in this one together let's you
know let's get me get me trained I'll
bring leadership and energy you know but
what does bad leadership look for look
like for a captain just for
informational educational purposes when
you say your captain was a bad leader
what was up with him so I always tell
everyone charcoal that you know you
enter the service
with your faith and your friends and
your family and your integrity and you
should leave the service when someone
tries to take that from you and so my
first Captain
was a liar and a cheater and
um he would steal things and he gave me
that he said hey take this truck to
Topeka
and trade everything that's in the back
of the truck to the guy and he's going
to give you some stuff and put it in a
truck and bring it back on Sunday I said
I'm not going and he said
your career is going to end right here I
said I'm ready for that I'm ready for
that you know there's nothing you can do
there's nowhere I'm going to end up not
doing this for you it's gonna you know
make it right so he said get out get out
of here he called in another little
tenant that guy took the truck
and it was a Chuck's full of stolen
goods or something yeah yeah you know
from
um he would he would end up getting
excess he'd trade internally to get
stuff and then you know he stole a
trailer and it was parked in the field
and he sent you know Supply guy hey go
hook that up to our supply truck bring
him back
because he could trade that for someone
who needed a trailer who had lost one
he's just a scumbag
okay so your first yeah yeah what makes
you decide you're going to stay in I
guess I guess you had the family
tradition so there was no yeah getting
out well
you know my mom was really strong uh
elegant woman from Boston and uh and she
would say hey if you don't like
something then you know get to the top
and change it and you know either and
then my father would probably add to
that if you walk out who do you think is
going to take care of those soldiers
so you know he would he would have
supported me leaving
um at the end of the first four years my
high school best friend at about year 16
said you've served 16 years for four
years of college you're a fool I said no
John I stayed in because I like it uh so
you so that's your first job
um out there in Fort Riley Kansas
sounds like you're learning some lessons
of at least how not to act yeah uh where
do you go from there well as you said I
went from the basic course
to Fort Riley they didn't allow my class
to go to Ranger school
so here I am a lieutenant with no Ranger
Tab and every you know
payday breakfast some general says if
you're an infantry guy and you don't got
a ranger tab then you're you're not
worth it so I lived four years and you
know the sort of a theme is wanted to go
to West Point didn't get in went to the
second string decided which none of my
classmates would agree with that but but
you know when you're 18 you're like oh
my gosh yeah damn it and then you go to
the basic course
you know your dad is a paratrooper and
and uh the distinguished Soldier he's
like okay I get my Ranger Tab and then
get ready to go to combat no no Ranger
tapped so so I came back to uh in 1983
went to then I'd been offered a bunch of
company commands as a lieutenant you
know stay here it's a captain's job but
you got what it takes and I had to tell
the Botanical Commander I got to move on
it's a big army you know I got I got
some things I got to fulfill so I went
back and about eight captains and again
the same number 200 lieutenants and
young sergeants started Ranger school
after the captain Square course and only
one graduate
and uh because it's too easy for them to
to say hey I've already I've been out
there I've already LED I got good
reports you know I can get I can get
what I need were you a captain yet when
you went through Ranger school that was
yeah so you went through Ranger school
as a captain what year was that like
1983 now we're talking 1984 or something
like that October 83 to uh to January or
December like did you prepare for Ranger
school like nowadays people when they're
going to some kind of selection they
they go through a pretty they if they're
smart they'll go through a pretty
hardcore training regimen to get ready
did you prepare training prepare for
Ranger school I did and and uh I'd be
you know Columbus Georgia
you know August and July August June 80
pound rucksacks when like you know and I
was probably a whopping you know 138
pounder 8142 you know and uh but other
guys are on the golf course and they're
laughing and joking and you know holding
the beer up and they see me and
my big black dog walking and then laying
the half you know like that shooting
asthma if I'd say
you know hey Kelly go out there go go go
go go go sit and then God Walk to him
and then send him again sit and all that
but uh then night Land Navigation you
know all the things not time all the
things that were going to come up you
know you spend the time you know and you
so you were ready for what were the
numbers that you just threw out there
you had how many people start this let's
say probably 228 and 228 and these were
captains they only eight were captains
so only eight captains had the courage
to uh try it again or try it because
they already were comfortable you know
complacency is a killer yeah it is and
uh and so in this case uh we started and
uh and only I only I graduated uh a guy
named Danny Green was recycled he later
graduated all the others quit along the
way and then if the 220 uh young
officers lieutenants and young Sergeants
probably about 48 made it so we probably
had a graduation around 50 starting 228.
what was what was the hardest part or
the biggest challenge for you in Ranger
school
uh I mean if you're 138 pounds I'm
surprised you even lived through that
you know food off everyone was 138 at
the end so I didn't have yeah I lost
probably about four pounds and I saw big
men lose you know lots
uh part of it was you know I've been
deployed with the unit from Fort Riley
around the country and overseas and and
I had done a lot of training
um we ran a basic AIT Advanced
individual training at the Army had an
idea to send them to the unit and you
train them up
so when I was going to Rainer school I
kept thinking they got to have a safety
net around here we're going down this
River it's going pretty fast so you know
they got to have a first aid tent around
here you know for hypothermia so I was
all I had already been to support
platoon leader in the Battalion you know
Logistics officer so I was just kind of
and and my my Ranger buddy was Ed Ruiz
he was a staff sergeant from the 82nd
Airborne and he thought he was going to
die he's like
we're gonna die anyway and all this
stuff you know to me I thought it was
like you know Disney World if you're
taller than Mickey you can get on this
ride here and so man I'm gonna get five
extra jumps this is great and and I
literally would you know he would eat
everything they gave him they'd give you
two meals uh for a day or three meals
for two days and I ended up just my work
was getting heavy with the c rations so
my work was getting heavy with extra
towel and then you know when he'd start
whimpering I'd go here you go take this
ears here's spaghetti here's you know
all that
um so you know everyone has a day or two
that are bad days in Ranger school and
uh and if you have your Ranger buddies
then they carry you through and likewise
you do it for them so you know to me it
was a leadership uh
you know uh opportunity and
just put one foot nut in front of the
other what was the most uh significant
leadership lesson you took away from
Ranger school
um you know I think you
if you're not building teams they're
falling apart That's A Life Lesson and
so you're you're constantly trying to
make the team stronger you're going
around uh and and probably learned it
because I thought that's probably the
right way to do it and uh and then when
you you see it come together and you see
that we can get through this together
kind of thing then you know and I you
know I start with a lot of those
enlisted guys all went to the ranger
battalions so then when I started
serving in the Rangers there's all my
Ranger buddies are now ncos that no cap
Affairs you know he's legit
when you get done with that what's your
next Duty station uh I went up to Alaska
and uh and
took it in Fairbanks North of the Arctic
Circle ended up taking command of the
parachute infantry company Charlie
airborne and we had 50 guys at a reunion
so from 1985
50 guys still get together
in Fairbanks Alaska and and the Arctic
the uke they call it it makes men you
know they they all come in the skinny
little legs and buck teeth and big ears
and no neck and after they carry the
rucksack through them through the winter
on snowshoes they're tightened they're
tight grouping hair studs they end up
with a thick neck big legs and smaller
ears yeah that's right exactly it's all
moving in the right directions so now
you're you're a company Commander you
said at that point I am and what was
your you know how what was your premise
you know from a leadership perspective
when you took company command how did
you what was your what was your first
sit down with the troops what did you
tell them what was your kind of your
principles of leadership
somewhere along that time
um
I coined the idea you know or the model
you know we win together and so it's
pretty simple but it's we
and it's together and it's about
outcomes and they all wore a maroon Bray
you know fancy hat and uh and they
thought they were invincible and and I
told them you guys you know we don't
live fire no one in the Army does but I
don't really care about that I care
about us
so first it was you know applied
Marksmanship basic Marksmanship then
applied Marksmanship and I would
challenge
the ncos and the reason I think we're
still together is okay let's let's
figure it out there there are great
shots in this world and everyone in
those companies do that and we will walk
everywhere so we'll parachute in and
we'll walk to the front gate There's No
Buses coming to the Drop Zone
all right we're going to be hard you
know not not full of ourselves but you
know
and so that we challenged uh my best
friend's company to a wrestling match
and uh so he got the NCO Club is all
kitted up and and when the first
paratrooper got pinned by a non-airborne
guy they couldn't believe it was like
wait a minute we're Superman we're
Airborne it's not okay so now the hype
and the reality let's work on this here
so we got to maneuver live fire level
and uh
um and they're they're just great so the
the whole thing is I think in life if if
you
um treat everyone like they're really
wicked smart and you know there were
guys at the Citadel that we walk around
like you know dumb privates and then
you'd see them on a basketball floor and
they were natural leaders and those kind
of observations taught me you have no
idea the fierceness in a platoon or a
company and you have no idea the talent
that's around you unless you let it come
out and so that was that's the way that
I do it I've done my whole life
so then uh
I get a call from Department of the army
hey you've been up there for three and a
half years we got something for you
and I said what do you mean they said we
we got we got a recruiting job down in
San Jose it's real close to your home
or recruiting or uh
reserve duty and I said
the phone lines up here in Alaska are
not that good I hung up
so I called down to Second ranger
battalion and I talked to a friend of
mine named Bernie champo I didn't know
him at the time but it became a long
friend
and I said hey I'm I'm coming out of
company command and I'd like to come
compete try to try out for the Rangers
you're supposed to be the best of the
best
and he said man you should have called a
year ago you know we're we're booked way
out and uh I said look I'm I'll fly down
there I'll give it a try whatever you
want he said I can't help you
then a guy quit and so he had my name
right there so you know
what is Wayne Gretzky says you miss
every you miss every shot you've never
taken and so he calls up says hey Mike
this is Bernie
um if you can be down here and it's like
I'm standing next to him here I am so um
so that worked out really did you have
to go through some kind of selection to
be an officer in in the ranger regiment
yeah yeah we we called it rope back then
Ranger uh orientation program now now
they use rasp yeah now they use rasps
okay selection program and how long was
this selection program
uh probably three weeks and you were
ready for that thing even though you
hadn't been preparing you've been
preparing just by being an infantry
company Commander up on Alaska humping a
rock and doing what you're doing and
wrestling against the the legs yeah
that's right exactly and again I'm the
basketball player in the uh and the
baseball player not not a Grappler yet
so that's what's really unique about it
so yeah so it you know
combat water survival test which is you
know simple and I grew up water skiing
and playing around and then uh shoot and
then
um
12 mile foot March five mile run in uh
35 minutes and
um so you the idea was one it was an
orientation program because they wanted
you to know how to tie your gear down
where it goes what see all the weapons
that you're gonna see when you get there
and and then uh but also to know that if
you take that unit if the day you arrive
they go on a 20 mile foot March you can
do it and and first of it's just an
investment a good good you know people
management
you want to waste time bringing someone
in and then have them to flop out
because they're just not fit
so you get a sign then you you get
assigned to the range regiment I do
as far as I can tell
and you know I I was in the Navy
obviously and I worked with the Marines
a lot I worked with the Army on
deployment I work with the Marines on
deployment
but and you know I work with special
opera or Special Forces I work with uh
marsok I've worked with kind of a bunch
of different units I've worked with
Rangers before I was live next Rangers
but but the from what I could tell on
the outside looking in it seems like
Ranger regiment is
kind of this the most uh Spartan of the
units out there in terms of the
day-to-day life of being a ranger and
I've also been told this by by friends
that were in in Rangers at ranger
battalion the life that you lead there
is like you're a ranger that's it
nothing else and what we're going to do
is be in the field and we're going to
train
and there's a lot of young kids there
it's a very young group you know got
because you can go right out of high
school the training you don't have to go
to Rangers school to go to Range of
Battalion right you can just go through
that two or three week thing and boom
you're now at a ranger in a ranger
battalion what was tell me a little bit
about the day-to-day life of being in a
ranger battalion yeah it was it's so the
day-to-day life started on Sunday where
you got a high and tight haircut every
Sunday and so you know you either had a
flat top or you had uh it looks like a
divot from a golf course landed on top
of your head and so and then so
everybody starts right there everybody
carried a ranger coin if you didn't have
your coin you get smoked you know or you
buy beer for somebody
so getting smoked is you're actually
like doing push-ups and PT like you're
in boot camp yeah so that kind of thing
doesn't happen I in it doesn't happen in
the SEAL Teams that's for sure like no
one's going to make you do push-ups when
you're in the SEAL Teams though you you
might if you do something really stupid
you might get slapped around you might
get actual Duty assignments but you're
not you're not walking around this
there's no there's no feeling of boot
camp whatsoever when you're at a Seal
Team yeah yeah Ranger regimen is not
like that you there definitely is a boot
camp yeah you don't want you know so I
end up commanding a company being a
battalion S3 being the regimental S3
command and a ranger battalion so you've
seen it at every level yeah and except
for the original Commander yeah you know
but but there's there's a rise of
Passage you know
um every officer who serves in the
ranger regiment has already done the job
so I recommended the parachute company I
come back and command a ranger company I
Commander to parachute Battalion in the
82nd came back and commanded oh God
that's smart Battalion S3 in the ninth
Infantry Division
and then Battalion has three for third
Rings battalion
in the enlist in the platoon there there
are
echelons I I joke about you know you you
just love it when a new private comes in
because he gets the green scrub pad and
you get the buffer right and so you're
no longer sticking your hand in the
toilet cleaning it right but uh that
until the ranger gets to Ranger school
he he's he's a lesser now they'll fight
you know in a bar together to take care
of him uh they'll fight in combat
together but there's there's you know I
have gone to Ranger school I'm a
Corporal E4 or I'm a sergeant E5 and you
have not
and uh your specialist that came from
Korea and we're saying E4 you're not the
same so that so it starts there in terms
of Spartan life
um the uh
you know the officer is supposed to eat
last you know make sure the troops the
Rangers got their child
and that kind of thing
um but everyone has to meet that
standard and so
uh if if
a guy falls out of a run falls out of a
foot March then
um the Army gave
uh summary release authority to the
range of Battalion and so you get
dropped and they send down to leg land
or send down to
9th Infantry Division or 24th after
division back in those days and so you
you had to stay on it and uh and you had
to learn to play hurt and so you're
jumping and walking through the night
and falling in things and you know if
you got hurt and you the wounded world
to be kind of syndrome you know the lion
see the one that's limping and you know
they'll go after the ncos or someone
will go after someone that's
um can't keep up and so so it's a good
it's a good tough life yeah the so you
get you get a haircut on Sunday you get
a high and tight on Sunday night we need
Monday morning aren't you going in the
field all the time don't they spend a
ton of time in the field and yeah and
all right they'll go
so first first of all there's no
other than
uh combat prep there's no picking up
trash that's what the divisions you know
on the same post though we'll do a
rotation of stocking the shelves in the
commissary being the gate guards and all
that Rangers don't don't do that and uh
so instead it's
probably in the rifle company it's
probably Tuesday morning out uh Thursday
evening back or through the week two
weeks on a Thursday back the weapons
clean and then that late into that night
weapons cleaning the next day
um hang your boots to dry somewhere and
then get a haircut
yeah and most guys don't spend
more than one tour at ranger battalion
is that accurate or not accurate yeah
but the the uh
I was at where was I I think I was at
either brag or Benning and there was a
guy who looked like he was made of you
know
leather and freaking muscle he looked
like he might have been 45 or 50 years
old he's in the he's in the commissary
and he's wearing like his Ranger panties
and like a ranger t-shirt and I'm like
this guy is 100 Ranger you know he's and
and I was I've always uh heard that most
guys they do like maybe maybe four years
hitch there maybe they'll do one more
but then they move on because of the
lifestyle is just so Spartan the the
scenery
senior ncos will stay and and a lot of
guys will go from private to platoon
Sergeant the same platoon you know 15
years that's awesome yeah and uh and
then and then some some leave
um if someone messes up then uh like I
said they'll they'll get uh
drop from rolls
um a release for standards RFS
and as you can tell them hey you can
come back you know six months you can
come back to this unit and never do once
they get to the soft life they're not
coming back they're not so but but uh
it's very close and tight because you
know you've got this this kind of cast
system but it's also it's a brotherhood
like none other yeah no so uh salute to
the Rangers every time I work with a
ranger you know what you're gonna get
you're gonna get a 100 professional
Soldier that's ready to do the job
anytime anywhere
uh outstanding what was from a
leadership perspective what did you take
away from the Rangers as a leader
um so it probably came out of there with
with what I would call my my command
philosophy which is funny because my son
Patty commanded the same Ranger company
that I did and uh the only time in in
history that a father-son command the
same Ranger company and he wrote me and
said many years later some 2006 he wrote
hey Dad I've written my command
philosophy at six pages would you read
it and I tell me what you think I said
no I won't read it no one else will
either I was going to read six pages I
said he said well what's yours I said
it's easy I've had it since since Bravo
Company 275. one is do your best
do what's right
improve daily
build teams
and take care of a little guy or show
that you care and never quit and so I
kind of came out of there with if you're
not doing that then
um you're probably falling behind and uh
as an older guy as an older officer or
as a general you know I would tell
everyone
um
do your best means don't try to be the
best
because the team suffers when you try to
manage yourself you know you know this
and then do what's right be true to your
wife and leave everyone else's alone and
they all look at that and and I said
this is not a religious thing man this
is you're going to ask them to go up
that hill you're going to ask them to
you know leave the airplane in combat
they trust you and too many senior
officers and Senior ncos
you know they cheat on their wives they
think it's no big deal and now the truth
police guy's fake you know
he lies to her then go out to anybody
right and then the rest is about the
building of the team and and uh
when I was in Alaska this guy
finance officer I pulled him to the cage
in the finance building because it's
private from Charlie Airborne we've got
no pay dues so I'd hear him in the first
arm's office saying
Jones no pay do all right son of motor
finance next morning no pay due means
he's not going to get any money yeah
okay and so
um the next day I hear Jones's voice
first sergeant you know students aren't
talking in there so I'm listening well
he didn't have enough copies when he
went over there for finance I kicked him
back so now he's got four copies
okay so the next day I hear his voice he
signed the copies in blue ink
and at that point I said that's enough
so I said the first word said sir I said
no this this guy's wife thinks he's an
idiot because he's working for free so I
go into financing the captain there
um what's my next door neighbor his
name's art
I said hey Art my privates no pay dude
he's been in here this is the fourth day
in a row
and he said oh what gosh we can fix that
what's the what was the problem well you
didn't have enough copies
yeah you gotta have four cops you got a
copy machine right there number two he
signed it in blue yeah we got a hundred
percent you know no deficiencies noted
in our inspection at that point I
grabbed it
I'm gonna kick your butt in front of all
your troops right here or are you going
to pay this kid right now
that you know that that word gets
through that the boss is gonna stand up
for us and I think that's what we we're
supposed to do so that's what I really
learned in those first two company
commands when you were at ranger
battalion are you going on deployment
anywhere or do you just were you just
staying in Fort Lewis yeah we traveled
the world okay yeah
um
back then we had jungle uh training in
Fort Sherman Panama so every year you go
there
um you'd go up into the Arctic Fairbanks
or or Fort Richardson or Norway or
something like that and then
um we you do a long-in-flight rig
parachute rig and then parachuting into
Germany and and move for three three
days and nights and then attack bad bad
tolls as a was a Army Airfield there
um went up to Boise Idaho jumped in the
desert we would go we'd go quite a bit
so you'd just go on big training
operations and and get back
Square your gear away get ready go do it
again go to the field and and then then
once every uh eight weeks you take two
weeks stand down and then twice a year
you take two weeks of block leave the
whole unit shuts and goes it's squared
away the Rangers don't play around uh so
what do you get what'd you do when you
got done with uh with with this tour of
the Rangers
um I I had to go next door and uh be in
the motorized uh infantry and and then
Desert Shield Desert Storm kicked off
and uh and then I went to Commander
general staff College
and then
um when I was in Commander general staff
College in 91 92 but the uh
regimental Commander came to interview
and we had about 20 Ranger company
former company commanders in the in the
course
and the word out was these guys this guy
this guy and this guy were going back to
the Richmond as majors and uh
and so I thought well they've already
picked but I stopped by to see the
colonel and General Buckner and what's
the regimental Commander he said oh God
I'm glad to see I heard you were gonna
go to 101st but I got a spot for you
so I'm here sir let's go when the
Gulf War went down where were you were
you in uh the command and general staff
college and how pissed off were you
during that time me and and you know
whatever it was 600 you know pissed off
captain promotables or Majors yeah
people tried to call back try to go back
to their unit and uh you know back in
those days a War lasted you know a
weekend yeah that one did last what 72
hours or 96 hours or something like that
yeah tornadoes that way just cause was
out oh yeah Grenada too did you go to
did you go to uh Grenada no I was in
Ranger school yeah and then what about
Panama
um I gave up the ranger company and six
months later Panama
man yeah so one of the things that I
would say uh to you and for this podcast
is there's there's a lot of times that
you don't get what you think is supposed
to happen in life you know and and like
the Lord is your assignment officer you
know and uh
um and I you know I should have been
it's not that's not a good way of
looking like that you know it's look
through the windshield and not the rear
view mirror and make something of what's
in front of you is kind of what I would
tell people so didn't get West Point
like got this at all didn't get Ranger
school got the weapons pretended didn't
get a rifle but since when I went to the
Ranger school I was like a blank disc or
you know somebody teach me how to how to
maneuver because I've been shooting
mortars you know then got up
to Alaska got the Airborne company got
Bravo Company in the in the Rangers and
that didn't get to go
but in each case you gotta you know go
with purpose do your best do a try take
care of somebody and things will start
to work out yeah well in those days
it was just a roll of the dice whether
you're going to get to go to war or not
and and in those days you might be in a
unit where you know you are not gonna go
so you still had to motivate the troops
or some of them didn't want to be
motivated and during those days we
invented something called urinalysis
they didn't have it prior to 83. and so
you you know had drug use and stuff like
that and uh and suddenly now you you
know who is and then you could punish
them or correct them and all that so the
Army changed a lot in in from 79 to
you know 94. so after college
and what did you learn there I mean
where what were you learning what was
your main main takeaways that you got
out of going to the two years of command
and general staff that's one year and uh
okay one yeah and
um someone told me that that the next 10
to 15 years of service will be with this
group so knowing that there are people
who are not infantry and they're squared
away they're smart you know and up until
then have kind of been sequestered into
all male infantry units and and one
thing I never left an infantry battalion
until I made Colonel and that's pretty
rare and so I was always finding a way
um you know to get back and uh
and different kind of History maybe and
then back to the Rangers and then
82nd Airborne then back to the Rangers
so so then that's what happens you get
they had a slot for you back at the at
the regiment and yeah first first at
regiment and uh
then General Grange or Colonel Grange
made me the Battalion or the regimental
S5 which could be civil military Affairs
but actually it was I want you to create
the ranger monument at Fort Benning I
want you to create the James Dietz
Prince I want you to create the pavers
and all that stuff and so
um
he he went to go worldwide because we
we'd been left out of uh Desert Shield
Desert Storm except for one Ranger
company from first Ranger
um Schwarzkopf didn't didn't like the
Rangers and he had been a Fort Stewart
and so he probably felt that they were
primadonnais and and so for whatever
whatever reason the Rangers didn't get a
lot of action
and so General Granger said then Colonel
Granger's view was I'm going to go to
each of the combatant commands and and
then arrange for an exercise so it will
be used
and then he came he would come back
and he asked the communication officer
there's these kind of radios Delta Force
has these kind of radios in order to you
know and you come back said what's the
word on radios and the guy go I can't I
didn't make any progress and then go to
this guy you know this kind of supply
stuff we needed this kind of Rapid
Deployable parachute thrown out from a
helicopter no action that he came to me
and I said here's the print you know
this at this print is the here's the
sketch and met with these guys in
Florida and that and and uh
so in 69 days at the regimental level I
was then sent down a Third Battalion
where everyone wants to be in a
battalion so it's the shortest I think I
was hailed and farewell to the same
social event
and that so now you get into the
Battalion and what are you doing offs
there yeah we have a extra field grade
in in the range of battalions who does
the special ops liaison and coordination
so for one and you're really schooling
yourself on on what the other S3 what
the S3 is going to do and you're
probably the error apparent
um so so I was yellow
and and uh after a year
um I moved into uh the S3 job
and then my botanic Manner and another
range of Italian Commander were killed
in a helicopter crash in the Great Salt
Lake
on October 29 1992.
so then
um Danny McKnight
came and took over third range of
Battalion and and
he he led third into Mogadishu with
Bravo Company and and they worked with
with the Jordan special operational task
force there
he he was not half the man of Colonel
corneli and I think it hadn't had a lot
to do with a lot of problems in the
street there
and uh
you know when you think about the
lieutenant colonel there's they're still
pretty young but when you're a captain
in a major you expect a lot from them
and if he's a ranger Commander you
expect a lot
so I was asked to be the chief of staff
of the armies Aid to camp
and
so where were you when when um did you
deploy to Somalia then I did but I
deployed after the big fight got it so I
brought Alpha Company and a squadron
um forward from from uh Delta Force and
we we had trained we were going to be
the replacement on October 3rd had the
big fight and we arrived
October 4th at about six at night
we did patrols got Mike Durant back
um and then
um
and then
the president President Clinton struck a
deal with Hadid and we thought we just
lost six of our buddies and Gordon
shugart lost
you know Sergeant Cleveland who was a
pretty good friend I did a lot of
missions with that
task force 160 and he was dragged
through the streets and then you see you
know and just giving up so
I'm very proud of the Rangers I think
Ranger Scotty Miller who retired as a
four star was the captain underground
for the Delta Force
and a great friend and great great great
officer person
I think any other unit in the army that
day would have been killed to the man
in my Bravo Company and and elements of
uh very Task Force Ranger did was
amazing remarkable and
encourages me on description
what was the when you so you land on
four October
what was the atmosphere when you get
there yeah it's really really eerie
Sullen we got mortared that night and we
one got killed and and uh
Dr Marsh
task force doctor wounded badly
Grizz Martin was killed he had been a
second range Battalion guy and then did
the Long Walk and joined
the guys are brag
um but it was Eerie
um there was sort of this
rationalization that occurred that you
know the ranger standard didn't have to
be followed because we were hanging out
with these cool guys
and I and I felt we sent my Colonel
there
ill-equipped to command because he
didn't have his staff and so I went I
think I felt when I got there that uh I
assumed that role of leadership again to
get the arena standard back up to speed
and I mean adding sandbagged you know
the place they were living in and
they're just kind of playing volleyball
and hanging out and then going on
missions and stuff so
and then and then never you know they
lost we lost some we lost six guys and
uh it means a lot to all these guys
and to me
yeah it was uh obviously just
the horrible I'm you know I was I was in
the SEAL Teams at that time and we were
all just
well I didn't have it we had Durant on
on the podcast and it was so uh
so
surreal to be sitting across talking to
him when you know like I said I was in
the SEAL Teams and we're watching you
know seeing the videos of him and
watching him get dragged through the
streets and watching the videos that got
posted or that were on the news
and you know you think this guy well you
want to do everything you can to help
him and obviously I'm like in I was in
San Diego you know I mean we're not
going to get to do anything to help him
out but
yeah what a what a tough fight
and a tough situation and
um so when you get done with that what's
your what's your next job after that
when
I became the regimental operations
officer we planned Haiti and I got ready
to go into Haiti and then I think
General Powell and a few others went
down there and broke her to Peace So we
were rigged on the airplane
clamshell
we are three hours from jumping into
combat
clamshell
and then actually
um that night my mom passed away so she
had cancer and uh
so an air force uh
tactical air control guy they drove me
from Savannah to a Ford betting where I
met my my wife and Margaret we linked up
with Margie and then she put him out and
played out to Monterey
to settle my the estate so the whole
time period
was from
kenneally Dyne
Mogadishu
Haiti
my mom passing and then one month later
I take Battalion command at Fort Bragg
and it probably was kind of numb for
about six months someone told me once
and you know you got that smile back you
got that sparkle back I didn't know it
was gone
yeah you must have been uh quite focused
when you showed up where'd you do your
first Battalion command it was Fort
Bragg and second Battalion 504th
parachute infantry and uh with the 82nd
with the 82nd uh first brigade Commander
was uh John abbazade a really great
officer and the second one is the Famous
Dave Petraeus so
um
General trace and I would race each
other and so the other Battalion
commanders when Patrick when when uh
then Colonel Petraeus would come out in
the morning and look around we'd all be
stretching and they'd run and hide
behind the bushes or their barracks and
so
he would say
white level six
let's go for a run
all right sir so then
we'd go two out two miles out and then
come back and at the beginning of the
fourth mile we'd race and so
I think he's probably caught me by about
three but I say hey surfing I want to
play 101 basketball first you know you
want to wrestle you want to you want to
do anything else but uh so we had a lot
of fun when he would come to Iraq later
um I would tell my we're gonna get a
call tomorrow night at 2300 to meet with
General Petraeus at zero four exactly
sir
you know so we we learned to take a day
off before the race the next day because
he would try to sneak in there and uh no
you probably smoked yourself the day
before and so so when you're doing the
Battalion command now
um at the 82nd are you guys doing a
workup cycle where you're training and
then you're moving to a higher state of
Readiness is that is that what you do in
the Army I'm in the Navy so our cycle
was always and it's the same with the
ships and then Marine Corps falls into
this too they do kind of what the Navy
does which is
get ready to go on deployment and then
you board ships and you go on deployment
and the SEAL Teams you get ready to go
on deployment we sometimes we board
ships sometimes we just fly to another
place and we stay on deployment for six
months that's sort of that's sort of the
methodology of the Navy and methodology
the Marine Corps too when you're at 82nd
and there's no war going on what do you
do yeah you have three Cycles
um
division ready force one two and three
if you're in two that's the Intensive
training cycle and
pre if you're good at it then before you
enter two you've done your basic
Marksmanship of all weapons so now you
can go straight into collective training
and then uh at the conclusion of that
eight week cycle of really field time
then you become very force one and all
your vehicles are rigged up to be para
dropped all your ammos ready to go so
you're basically on standby at that
point yeah and then
um if you're on three
you can take your block leave or you're
picking up trash and just you know
stashing shelves into commissary and
stuff
you legit do that soldiers legit do that
stock channels in those commissary
I did not know that I don't think anyone
in the Navy stock shelves in the in the
commissary in the Navy I don't think so
yeah I could be wrong yeah but at least
in the SEAL Teams we didn't I don't know
yeah when you try you know when you're a
new officer the first time in 82nd and
you try to tell a sergeant major my guy
shouldn't be stocking shelves
that dog doesn't hurt very long in the
80 Seconds what'd you take away from
General abbazade and Colonel Petraeus at
that time
well
um
so attributes were they're very focused
one intensely focused General Petraeus
the other focused and very cordial very
friendly
um
one very good listener one a pretty good
listener
um and so I and seeing is Who is the
very good listener who is the pretty
good listener Joe abbaside was was a
very good listener he's just curious as
heck and General Petraeus was prone to
um
think he if he knew what he wanted then
he didn't need to listen as you know you
just had to be a little smoother at
bring it up you know sort of be helpful
and useful if maybe you know those kind
of discussions
um I have great relationship with both
of them really great and but they're
little little different leaders
when um
as a as a battalion Commander would you
take away as a leader did you make any
big mistakes did you have any huge
Lessons Learned as a battalion Commander
I I so the first was understanding
really you know
um
who who did you need to own their heart
what level did you need to own their
heart to know that the unit would do
anything for you
so at a company level you know all 180
guys or 160 or whatever you know and if
you get the E4 Mafia kind of with you
um then you the companies can do
everything and and
the uh at the staff sergeant and
Sergeant E5 right in the middle of that
was where the Battalion Commander so so
how do you get that well you got to run
PT with them you know you got to roll
with them you know you gotta be on that
foot March
when when they step off for the expert
infantry badge you got you know not only
do you step off but you you beat
everybody
a 12 mile for March so they know they
know he he can do it
you stand up to the Brigade Commander
when they you know somebody's ragging on
your guys you go sir you know it's not
your job
you run a brigade I'll run a battalion
and uh I got this so that you got to
earn their trust
um so I think I learned that when you
can do that then you can do anything
then what was the so the you just were
telling me that the you do in Rangers
you already did the job somewhere else
so now did you go is this when you did
Battalion Commander at Rangers after
that yeah I went down to Fort Benning
from from brag at this at that time and
took third range of a time and this is
what 1996 1997 time frame yeah it's 96
to 98.
and
this is where you get your introduction
to jiu jitsu am I correct it is yeah and
what was that introduction like
uh it happened this way what you know
what it was like it was awesome but it
happened this way then Colonel I'm a
Crystal Stanley Crystal
um
asked me hey what do you what do you
think about uh bringing these guys hoyce
Gracie and hori and Gracie
um in and training year Sergeants
this idea of hand-to-hand or combative
so
and and I said well sir what's that
going to cost me and he said it's forty
thousand dollars for two weeks
well we didn't even have night scopes on
all of our machine guns in 1996 . I said
so I'd rather take that money and put
put it in the Scopes you know
and he said okay good good
um you're gonna do it I just want to
know how you felt about it so that's all
right so then within a week or two
um I walk into the range of dining
facility and there's these two guys
sitting at the table
somebody introduces them to me and you
know I'm looking at a horse great this
close so I'm thinking I wonder what do
you do if I slapped him right now
I didn't slap him I was going to say I
actually do know what he did yeah I know
we all know that but they uh they
introduced
um
ground fighting in the form of Gracie
Jiu-Jitsu and I asked them you know why
are you winning and he said you know my
you know our father
um took the Japanese style of fighting
and and put the Brazilian side on it and
and we can win and we will win
so I I our a recurring theme is to trust
and and super backup your your
non-commissioned officers and so
set up the training and then we pure
fleeted it
and uh right as I started to understand
it then the Army sent me to Boston so
um went up there went into Kenny
Florian's Place once or twice and uh
um and I trained with his brother Keith
about two months ago it was pretty good
pretty pretty awesome time and but uh so
third range of battalions were
combatives was introduced
I went to the Fletcher School of Law and
diplomacy in Tufts University as you
know I was joking say that's a senior
National Defense fellow so let's show a
little respect around here with a title
but then when I came back there's
another one of those examples
um there's a lot to talk about third
range Battalion and learns and live
fires and and uh guys getting killed and
uh and hurt and training uh is that
during live fire
Evolutions uh guys getting killed at a
demo range we had someone put P for
plenty you know just trying to let's get
rid of it all and through a dirt clog
of clay in the air that was the size of
a piano or something and landed on on
guys that were behind tomorrow yeah
and uh but you know you you learn when
you're doing these things that it's
dangerous and if you do what's right go
back to that one you're going to be okay
if you're with the right people you're
going to be okay but when you do
something wrong what did the
investigation on that look like I mean
what was the if you if you're talking to
a young Soldier right now A young Ranger
right now
what would they take away from that
there was negligence and and you know
the master breacher was found was
court-martialed and departed the army
and what was he what was his thought
process I just said bigger boom not not
trying to be show off you but more like
look if we continue to do this we're
going to be here till 10 at night so
then let's put it all in the hole and
let's get out of here no kidding
how much explosives
you know I let me make the one
correction I was that happened when I
was the S3
and and I was in uh Mogadishu when it
happened
so
um
so I got investigated for having signed
off on the uh
the range request
and then deployed and so then did the
OIC and the ncoic were the ones that
were finally found responsible
and then what other what other major
takeaways did you have from Battalion
command at Ranger regiment
you guys you talked about live fire yeah
what was uh how much live fire would you
guys do live fire maneuver well we did a
lot we did we did uh company live fires
so so in that train up for the Rangers
to take the mission in a similar way as
in the 82nd we would always do a short
Readiness exercise which meant we had uh
helicopter assets from the 168th and
from Air Force Special Ops and he had
gunships in uh and then you know
sometimes it would be there's a there's
a there's a special forces location in
Copa Peru so we rebuilt it to uh
um to seize it back should uh was a
shining path or whatever and they had
taken it then then we would live fire
take it back so it's always built around
some kind of ongoing actual objective
out there yeah yeah and then again you
you want range of platoons to
um be be the best platoon size element
that can OverWatch support by fire
breach assault consolidate you know can
uh breach any any kind of fence door or
whatever and so you you string a lot of
The Blocking and tackling and then you
put it into a concept and
um
which is interesting because a lot
in the 20-year War which we call
this one we're just finishing up we're
still working on
a lot of our officers are sort of like a
latch you know latch key kids they
everything's been given to them they
haven't had to conceptualize
and visualize conceptualize put it
together and understand angles and and
um
you know moving Force stable force and
so I think we learned a lot about about
that also in in range of a tank command
now you're on you have to know things
about three levels up
um when you're a company Commander you
gotta sort of know what the Battalion
Commander thinks well as soon as you get
to Battalion then suddenly it's jsoc and
all the assets it's you know combatant
command and or their Sif forces
current terrorist forces
host nation and partner Nations so
there's a lot of that I think the
biggest thing is just how smart
the ranger officers and the senior ncos
are that's that's when you realize oh my
goodness you know I had four company
commanders one of whom is Eric Carrell
now a four-star
they were all West Point classmates and
they were great guys and they were but
they're so smart and they would vote us
a block so they'd come walking into the
office like oh here we go all right but
if I needed to do anything I would say
to
to Jeff Martindale is Eric doing okay he
seems kind of Droopy these days and a
minute later Eric be in my door sir what
I'm good to go so I think you you know
you learned that
um that they're not as experienced
but they're you find out that wow these
guys are really smart and the senior
ncos you know probably all ncos but you
get to see it at the senior level you
know really smart
you know from a training perspective in
the I grew up in the 90s in the SEAL
Teams and we did live fire everything I
mean we did live fire everything in fact
that was pretty much the only way we
trained was live fire we did live fire I
ads we did live fire odds at night we
did live fire CQC all the time that's
that's what we did blanks kind of wasn't
even a thing
and I would you know hear about the Army
hear about the Marine Corps and they'd
be talking about using blanks we I mean
I would personally my own ego would be
like well you know it's so lame that
they're doing blanks and we just did
live fire everything everything was live
fire didn't even think about it it
wasn't even a question what we were
doing we're doing live fire but in the
2000s we started actually using both
simunition and we had a better form of
Miles gear that was very high speed and
very very realistic and we started using
that and all of a sudden it made us so
much better both those things made us so
much better we do less live fire than we
used to but we're a lot better because
now we go against we go against an enemy
that's maneuvering and shooting back at
us and killing us and we're having down
men and all that stuff and then when I
ran training I I was really focused on
that force on Force training did you
guys see that did you see that kind of
transition as well we did and uh
especially going back and forth from big
army to to the Rangers you would see and
the the Advent of the combat training
centers
um joint Readiness National Training
Center and uh the cmtc over in Germany
now you had a world-class opt for and
that that's what took the Army out of
the doldrums of of post Vietnam to
suddenly everyone's getting there asking
you got to fight you got to know what
you're doing yeah and so then it's like
and then you have world-class Observer
controllers that are saying you know
you're the 14th iteration of that I've
seen you're not that good yeah you know
and not publicly but off the side and
it's it's you know it's on the same rank
they're saying you know your planning is
not that good your communication is not
that good your action's not injected
aren't that good so you know here's your
take-home packet or you get better
and then you got a mission in two days
you didn't you didn't rehearse anything
get you guys out of rehearse when did
they stand up that NTC
and uh
was it in the 2000s was it no no no no
it was uh 80 85 oh okay so they've had
it for a while yeah they're already
brought in the combat training center
the Blackhawk the M1 tank and the
Bradley all all within a five-year span
that's a big transition yeah all right
so you get done with uh School
you're up there and then you come where
do you go back when you when you get
done with that where you go yeah so
um you know God had decided that I was a
Ranger with a capital R so I should
probably command the 75th Ranger
regiment didn't happen so they sent me
to the 11th infantry which is the school
Brigade
and you know talk about humility
um you know having to suck it up and
like oh my God you know
plan a ranger company parachute company
parachute Battalion ranger battalion Ops
and then a training regimen and then
training and so I had officer candidate
School
infantry officer basic course jump
that captains Advanced course or career
course and then the Battalion of dogs
and cats and now if you're we had a
little issue with this in the field we
used to have an issue with this in the
SEAL Teams where no one wanted to go to
training
and especially the Advanced Training
what we now call training Detachment but
it used to be called training cell where
you're actually training the platoons
that are going to go work and uh
you learn so much there number one but
number two it's real it seems real
obvious that you would want to take your
best guys and put them where they're
training the other guys as opposed to
taking the turds and putting them in
charge of training
so did you were you able to make that
mind shift after you got assigned to the
training and realize you're gonna have
an impact on a bunch of people that are
coming through training including the
basic infantry officers course yeah yeah
right away and and uh
probably
in July of of uh 99
I was you know moping around and my wife
would normally will say Okay moping
time's over let's you know what are we
gonna do with this and so that the
entire generation that fought in Iraq
and Afghanistan started underneath he
started uh
the captains I wouldn't allow the
captains to stay more than 11 months in
any job so they had to go back to their
divisions otherwise they were going to
be dead in the water they wouldn't make
major and so all these guys will learn
how to train had first sergeants were
running training companies all they were
in the first wave of captains and many
of them are two and three star generals
now and all that so big impact and then
also I got called up to uh
a four stars office tradoc commanding
General's office and he said that okay
you got the lieutenant course they're
too soft the lieutenants are bunch of
wimps you know all they do is Powerpoint
they you know once you do a quick study
come back here in three weeks and tell
me how you're going to change base the
training for all the officers in the
army
so
um so we found out we did analysis real
quick and found out that
of the 16 basic branches only four
qualified with the base with with a
rifle
well out of how many out of 16 branches
I think it was artillery infantry
um
Engineers engineers and armor and
everyone else might might fire a weapon
might might not why and so this is
before 9 11.
um so I designed the course with a
couple of the sergeants and a couple of
officers
and and we did the same same thing we
did in the Rangers it's like okay Monday
you're going to the field you know and
then you're going to shoot every week
that you're in a basic course
we purefully did that and then the
culture to the other branches about
three years after I left you know went
to their generals of quartermaster
generals of Finance or whatever and got
got away
but I also saw the opportunity to
insert combatives into
every course and I had to fight you know
the big organization they're like you
can't you can't do combatives you don't
have
the manual says you should have a
fairbane knife and you know fight like
the Brits did in World War II so we
wrote that the TC that you talked about
and the credit goes to Matt Larson and
Troy Thomas
Troy just retired his Lieutenant Colonel
Matt
um long friend and black belt for under
jockery
they did they did the hard work I did
the review and all that
and and then they said to you you can't
do it because you don't have any master
trainers so we created a master training
course you can't do it because you don't
have a facility I traded two pallets of
MREs for the book Warehouse
and this guy was a deer hunter who was
the uh the uh post Ops guy the military
post and and I said hey Colonel Jordan
I'll give you what what can I what do I
have to give you to get the book
Warehouse he says what a bunch of MREs
would be helpful because I'm out on
so in OCS when they finished their last
training exercise they just throw MREs
into the basement it's a big room so we
bundled them up traded and then we went
to two different high schools and got
the first wrestling match we pieced it
together so you know again the lesson
learned is reject rejection and if you
know it's right and then even
several of the course directors didn't
want their lieutenants captains or or
officer candidates
rolling around on the mats and so we who
says that yeah what kind of what kind of
human being what kind of soldier says
hey I don't want my my troops to learn
combatives that seems insane to me it
was it was and so you just play through
them and the captains would sneak down
there and and again all of them ended up
being
um combat commanders as captains and
majors and Battalion commanders in
combat and and they all they all got it
and our ncos got it right away it's at
the staff sergeant level they got it
right away and those were all commands
our majors and you know Division and
starting the Army level announced and
what year is this this is like around
2000 that all this is happening yeah how
long did it take you to get that manual
the first combatants we published it we
published it by uh
I took over July of 99 probably by July
of 2000.
then where are you at when September
11th happens
I was standing outside Admiral nadder's
office at Joint Forces command in
Norfolk Virginia and we were about to go
to
uh up to Iceland to do that we had an
air base up there that we were
responsible for and we were just he was
just going to go do a European tour or
something sort so I was in The Briefing
on the trip and he and boom we see the
first plane on his TV
Boom the next and I'd been assigned
there
four weeks maybe came out of Brigade
command again we're supposed to go to
Pentagon supposed to go to join staff
ended up in Norfolk what's the mission
of The Joint Forces command it was uh
the idea of secretary Rumsfeld that that
we needed an honest broker to select
um to use the Navy's Global Force
present posturepressants
to use the the idea of the MU rotation
to uh division division rotations
brigades Aviation he sort of solved some
that we were we needed some broad
coordination between all the services
and the whole supply chain and all that
it was a big time uh disruptive
innovation nobody liked Joint Forces
command nobody and uh and so you know
it's like you go down everyone wants to
stay in their Silo they do yeah well
we're happy no one bothers us we called
we called Norfolk the colonies we'd go
up to the Pentagon and say we're going
back down to the colonies you know so
but uh so I was there and then and I'm
sitting there thinking I'm going to miss
another damn War I cannot believe this
how can I be in the Army all this time
and everyone's deploying and then I'm
the deputy j3
preparing the deployment order for every
unit in in the military and I'm thinking
oh and then
um
uh so we're I'm there until
2004 so
from 911 to 2004 watching everyone go to
war and then someone said you know
you'll you'll make General if you can
get your boots dirty
and you know your everything's good
except for you
so then uh General Honore and and
general Vines J.R Vines
pulled me out of there and sent me to be
the assistant division Commander
um and I had in Iraq I had I had all the
MPS
all the aviation all psy-op civil
Affairs and our armies off and so I went
everywhere and on the road a street that
I didn't drive what year was that 2005.
okay
and what was your explain what your job
was
they they had these separate brigades
that would rotate in and there wasn't a
division headquarters on top of them a
two-star and there wasn't a one star and
so they were kind of just running their
own thing what each Brigade combat team
was they were Aviation brigades okay and
military police brigades got it got it
got it okay and so I became the sugar
daddy for for them and how long was that
first deployment over there that was uh
just under six months well not long and
then what was your what was your what
were you what was your Viewpoint of the
war look you watched the thing happen
you're kind of detached the first three
years of the war
actually first four years of the war
you're seeing the direction that it's
going
uh you know actually I was just talking
about on this uh podcast yesterday with
the guy who was with me in in the Battle
of ramadi Lake
and
I was saying we're we're not winning
we're losing this war this is now in
2006. a lot of people weren't saying
that you know a lot of people were like
oh yeah we're winning you know well my
Battalion did this many missions that
must mean we're winning and my Brigade
did this many missions that must mean
we're winning and we caught this many
bad guys that must mean we're winning
and so we're winning and that was there
was a lot of that going on
were you seeing that when you had it
over there did it look any different
when you got on the ground were you
starting to question whether we were
winning or not
yeah I I I'd agree with you I think
um first of all
you
you saw a lot of
transactional you know leadership in
other words we've got this units in we
own this piece of ground and we're out
of here on July 4th
we know that and
um so you saw good hard work you know to
search the next time I went was at the
tail end of the search
and I went three times and so I I would
have people would ask me a question like
you just said and I would say well when
I play golf with my friend Chuck and I
hit the ball over the hill and there's
water down there I'll say Chuck do you
think I went in the water and he goes
sir too close to call and I felt that
way about Iraq the whole time when
someone say are we how's that going to
end up on Nightcore is too close to call
um I think that
the Kurds and the Iraqis could screw up
anything and you know that doesn't get
me in trouble but culturally
they they can't take the win you know
and uh I think it's the Arab culture
that you know the grew all the way back
to to uh
you know coming out of the Far East are
these camels and everything and they
they have to trade and they say hey can
we have I'm the shake can I have six
camels and all those rugs and the guy
goes no no no no no but the shake was
powerful he'd go back to his village and
say I asked him they heard what I wanted
you know we gave him water they gave me
one rug and all that so that they're
Traders
they do Trading they also have multiple
wives and the wives promote their child
and the one who becomes
you know when you say Abu Mash that's
that's the father of mosh so that that
tells the tribe wash or you know Abu
Zaid
or abizade so Abu Zaid is is the father
of Saeed
and so they so that there's maneuvering
always yeah and um so
they you know they know that a new
brigade is coming in new brigade
commander and they can get another
Suburban when that guy shows up
and all that so they I think I think
that that's the problem and you know my
my third job there their tour
Iran advising and training so my team
trained all the national police the
police
the Army Navy oh small what year was
this
2000 and
2010 what'd you do on the second
deployment
I was dcg for operations Deputy
Commander general for operations at the
for the three-star headquarters under
General Lloyd Austin I I ran the Army
Special Ops
we had a CJ soda but that you know all
about over there but within the core's
area of operations it was a
the CJ soda really was Arabian Peninsula
and then inside
Iraq itself was uh what would be Brigade
uh Commander or joint Special Operation
task force and general Lawson gave them
to me he said you you speak their
language and what year was this 2000 it
was 15 months it was a long tour 2008
2009.
so the surge was 2008 right six I think
six or seven yeah maybe seven I guess
because it didn't I was in my last
appointment over there was 2006 the
search wasn't happening okay yeah um I'm
just trying to figure out when when uh
you know what was going on when you were
there so you were you had oversight of
the siege of sodiff in Iraq during that
tour the Brigade Commander everyone's
got a thousand fathers you know you're
going back to brag but the Brigade
Commander direct reported to me I
approved the nightly missions
um if you know we went into whatever was
Hillier hill whatever it was yeah that
was uh prime minister maliki's Hometown
we shot up his nephew there's something
we shot at our SF guys first and they
shot and killed him and so then so I'd
meet you're the guy Channel awesome with
the photos and with the tape
show and then I'd go to the Prime
Minister and show him
um
here's what happened you know you know
we'd like to pay the family or we're not
paying a family they shot at our guys
first and he's dead
um
did a lot of
efp hunting as as uh the makers or the
deliverers coming out of uh
out of Iran
and then uh
we had it we had a Iraqi Special Forces
um
version of they would live in this Camp
take all the uniform off go home once a
month and then come back and nobody knew
who they were but we went into Soccer
City I went in with them a couple times
and then uh
and then around big uh
high level uh
psychological operations and
influencing operations
now
2008 when that surge happened it sounds
like you were there you started to you
know this was something I was tracking
on you know with General Petraeus and no
more drive-by counter Insurgency we had
to get out and this is what we did in
ramadi the battle of the body we went
into the city you know and we is the one
one A.D who's going into the City and
setting up combat outposts and whatnot
you got to see that take place
throughout the the whole country
um and then did you start to think maybe
we can actually
for lack of a better word win
I think you feel that way first of all
commanders are optimists and uh it's a
good thing to be
um
it's a bad thing to not be a realist but
um you could be optimistic considered
and then you'd see the gains
um being made and for my role at that
time you know I'd roll into a battle
space see one of those Lieutenant
Colonels I might have been a captain
underneath me previously been during
those days
see how much they've grown up see feel
the cohesion of their their organization
um see what traps they were running
against the uh Al Qaeda or or whoever
um
which I I think you still got to
characterize it as optimistic but also
knowing that
um
at some point we can't sustain you know
80 000 men and women here we can't
sustain this budget or we can't if if
they can't take it over from us then
it's not going to work yeah that was a
big thing I had to tell my guys because
we had to start working with Iraqi
troops and of course all my guys are
like you're kidding me these guys are
terrible they're not trained they're not
trustworthy they don't have any
equipment but what I had to tell them
was hey if we don't get these guys
trained up where they can actually go
out and control the level of violence in
their City then we're going to be here
forever our sons are going to be here
that's what it's going to be and that's
a losing that's a losing proposition and
the guys understood that and moved
forward and certainly we were absolutely
successful in ramadi and and that was
based on what uh General McMaster did up
in talafar and then General uh McFarland
went and relieved him and then since it
had been pacified they took General
McFarland and sent him down to ramadi
who relieved General gronsky who went
home with his troops and
and that's where they did they
implemented that that strategy inside
the city of Ramada you go in set up
combat outposts in the neighborhood
start to get to know the local populace
and all that so we and we left and when
we left
within months after we left the ramadi
was like a completely different place
there was the level of violence was
almost went down to nothing uh you know
you had Sheikh satara bazio was out
there they were forming up there we had
there was like 30 police 30 Iraqi police
that were pretty much collecting a
paycheck and not do anything when we
showed up in ramadi now there was 2 000
of these guys so there was a massive
transition and it did look hopeful from
from our perspective back here looking
at the trans transition that had
happened in ramadi we started seeing it
in other cities and you were there for
that what did that what did that look
like on the ground for you yeah that the
other big task I had was to convert the
sons of Iraq
um so what we were what we had was 104
000 Sunni men that Sean McFarland
started uh
getting getting the uh the Sawa or The
Awakening going and and uh and so the
thought was hey if we can get them on on
every street corner then we we can get
out of there
I ended up having to uh brief Malarkey
about every other week on a Wednesday
and showing him
we went around to every promise there's
a Iraqi uh Special Forces two-star
General mooth there who was sort of
there
their God you know their Warrior God so
he and I would go we'd break the shakes
we bring the U.S Brigade Commander or
the Coalition Brigade Commander
um the police we'd get them paid uh 300
a month and then
um after six months then the Iraqis
would
during that time they're actually would
learn to pay him and then after that the
Iraqis money would pay him and so we
converted it all and then about a year
after I left
um that she had started
our calendar the sunnis and and then
that drove them into the arms of Isis
and that drove you know that search
again is there anything that we could
have done different in that transitional
period you know we we ran into all those
problems we had the Shia Army coming
into ramadi the the obviously ramadi's
filled with a bunch of Sunni we had the
Sunni police like I said there wasn't
very many of them but there was
definitely some some antagonistic
relationships there but we did see a
unification of the Shia Army and the
Sunni populace against al Qaeda like we
absolutely saw that they neither one of
those people neither one of those groups
wanted Al Qaeda insurgents inside the
city and so there was a brief time of
unity but it seems like where we dropped
the ball is not nurturing that
relationship to continue to be positive
maybe it's impossible I don't know
um but do you think there's anything we
could have done better
I think understanding them better is the
first step in other words
because of that brother thing so it's me
against my brother and then it's me and
my brother against another family and
then it's our tribe against another
tribe and then it's you know all the way
up to the Muslims against the world yeah
and so
um
that they're a culture of of uh
self-interest and so you have to that
there's no the loyalty is very low and
so when you say we're going to leave and
now you got this there's got to be
something in it form and if if you so
what can we do better is fine that's
whatever that was yeah I was rooting for
Walmarts
I thought if there was more Walmarts and
you could employ people and they could
have a place to go get a job and they
would have a place to go and get uh
burgers and get um you know Cheetos
we've made some progress
you know but we when we left we just
expected things to work themselves out
and what you end up with is a rift
there's no Walmart to to get to go and
work together that's what I'm saying
like you want to give them something
give them some kind of Commerce give
them some kind of positive because it
takes generations to get rid of and look
maybe they never get rid of those things
but eventually you're living right next
to each other eventually you say you
know what this is a little bit easier if
we if we all are doing if we're all
working together instead of working
against each other but we just
we I don't think we recognize the depth
of the rift between the sunnis and this
year which is which is completely
pathetic not to recognize that's
pathetic not to understand that I mean
to say that to say that we didn't
understand it
everybody knew it I mean look my I I
knew that at my levels my platoon
commanders knew it my my senior ncos
were like oh yeah we've got sunnis we've
got she is we've got to make sure they
get along so we on the ground knew it
but boy we didn't end up at a higher
level figuring out a solution to that
stuff no no we didn't and uh you know
creating you know within the Parliament
and then within the provincial you know
get equal representation and uh
you could even say I mean Maliki so when
we got to ramadi
we thought we actually had the op plan
we were going to do la falluja Style
just complete smash of ramadi we're
gonna go in there massive kinetics and
kill all the bad guys and and get rid of
them
Maliki said you know Malik is a Shia and
he said if we do that if I if I send my
Shia Army into
ramadi was filled as soon as it's going
to look like you know it's going to look
like uh extermination it's going to look
like genocide we can't do that and so we
took a different approach
so Maliki understood that he knew that
he couldn't do that yeah we we just
didn't it's like we it's like we just
dropped that ball you know we're heading
towards the end zone we just dropped the
freaking ball
yeah you think about the uh
you know 50 or 60 years of Peace in uh
occupied Germany
um in Korea in Japan and and uh
because we Remain the presence there
like I said learning that as a kid in
Berlin
and I think when we went back behind the
wall of the embassy then you know we
were telling first we moved our our
footprint out to
um al-assad in the middle of nowhere
yeah and so now you know they're like
there's some Americans here but they're
not uh
you know they don't got to get in the
game anymore yeah and it's amazing what
the American presence brings to peace I
mean it really does I I you know when we
left I don't think there's a one single
military person when we left in 2010
2011 that thought oh this is gonna go
this is this is gonna work smooth now I
don't think there's anybody that thought
that
and I don't think it would have taken a
huge American presence to keep things
you know it's like the
the school teacher in a room right the
school teachers in the room the kids are
pretty much doing what they're supposed
to do that school teacher leaves the
room it's Mayhem it's Mayhem that's
that's what happens and it's not like
the school teacher has equal force to
whatever 25 high school students they
can't they could easily overpower that
high school teacher but the presence the
understanding of consequences even the
understanding that you're being observed
like all those things make a difference
and when we when we just walked away
everybody I mean I was sick everyone was
saying this is there's this is going to
be this can be a disaster and sure
enough it was yeah we we asked for 14
000 troops and uh and was like a
permanent presence on the ground yeah
and that would have been an update
absolutely you know to have a mosul
presence and a you know up by Spiker and
then in Baghdad and uh out in the belts
it would have been it would have been
enough because now
the school teacher size has the shakes
and and the Iraqi generals to hold them
accountable and to continue to ride
around with them and all of that and uh
but that was denied and it went from
four thousand fourteen to four to three
to two to Over the Horizon Kuwait and
and we and we just saw how it played out
in Afghanistan as well and we also got
to see how it played out to have what
was it 3 000 troops on the ground that
were in Afghanistan for 18 months and
there was really low levels of violence
and you just were gonna let that wound
heal you got to let these let these
wounds heal over and let these
relationships starts to form and it
might like you said take a generation or
two generations 50 60 years and in the
meantime okay
it's good it's good it's good training
for our guys to be over there and
working with these understanding these
different cultures and and just this
this lack of any kind of presence and
then there was the um
you know people were calling Afghanistan
like this forever War it hadn't been a
war it hadn't been a war for the last 18
months before we pulled out it had been
a a peacekeeping observation of what was
happening and maintaining some presence
that that we could continue down the
path that we were on and now I mean it's
just been a complete disaster
yeah exactly and you know whenever I
hear on the news or someone says
you know the troops are tired of this
yep
whoever's saying that isn't a true you
know
and tired of picking up trash and Fort
Riley and when you're you know division
ready three or
not having sufficient uh bullets to to
uh to do live fires that's when troops
get tired and troops get tired look you
put them into a strenuous combat where
they're losing their friends yeah you're
gonna get tired but when you say hey
you're gonna go your friends and your
brothers and sisters in in arms have
gone and sacrificed so much and we're
gonna go but we've gotten to a place we
can maintain this that's what you're
gonna go and do you're doing something
positive and productive in the world
troops say Roger that I got it let's go
yeah you're right there's no there's no
fatigue for troops that are going on to
play going on deployment anyways let's
go do something that counts
so we definitely dropped the ball on
that and this is what you saw in your
last deployment so your last deployment
was in what year it was uh
all of
2011. so you were there for the shutdown
yeah I I was asked to stand up the
office of security cooperation which uh
we have we have around the world
different different names Mill groups
Office security cooperation office of
Defense cooperation so this was called
security and
um I worked for
Ambassador Jeffers and general Austin at
the same time and knowing that my
replacement who was going to be Bobby
castle and general Castle
um that he would be working for the
Ambassador out of the embassy
um and so we downsized
to 10 locations where we would have
mostly contractors
who would just maintain the helicopters
maintain the M1 tanks that we gave them
maintained the mraps and teach their
them the maintenance and so that that
was
John Ross was a four-star I was a three
star and this was your second time
working for General Austin hey Louis and
how was your relationship with General
Austin it was great yeah and and his
attitude about all this was he did he
have the right Focus did you feel like
comfortable with the decisions he was
making I I did yeah and uh he's uh
he's a really really great leader I
don't know what's going on in his
current job you know
um and I haven't spoken to him in a
couple of years but uh
you know fight for the troop take care
of the troops you know what will go
after someone when they're bad bad guys
he doesn't
he's going to let loose the dog's War
um
very thoughtful big thinker in that
regard
understood you know his role was setting
conditions and being out here and then
being in the street where the trims can
see him and then letting his layers of
two stars and Brigade commanders or
Squadron commanders do their part so
and then so so are you there when the
actual pullout happens when we're
finally done no I left November 2nd and
um I think they went out
um
two months later or something like that
am I accurate when I say that people
that everyone that was in the military
looked at it and and uh thought it was
going to be a disaster did you think
that too or did you have hope
when we're resourced I had hope and and
going down to 2000 not not having a
presence then that would be hopeless and
in your circles
you know with General Austin is their
pushback going back up the chain of
Commander people saying hey you know Mr
President this is look we got a bunch of
people that are saying this isn't going
to work out well is that what's
happening it is yeah and and
do you think it's political pressure on
President Obama that makes him say yeah
you know what we're we're out
I think um you know and it's really
officer Tommy wants the first rule of
the regime is to remain the regime and
the second rule of the regime is to
remain the regime
and so yeah I think uh the polling or
anything else the news Cycles
um they were playing not more than
a national strategic and defense which
is strange because Obama's an articulate
guy that I think could do a good job of
selling what's the selling snow to an
Eskimo he seems like that type of guy
that could say hey here's the situation
we thought we're going to be able to
leave looks like that that's not going
to be the best plan here's our here's
our adjustment
does that make sense I think so I think
so
um I you know
I think politics drove it why they did I
don't know you know why he would choose
this that way versus another I don't
know
and and it's just a complete create a
complete vacuum over there yeah again I
go back to 1968 Berlin you know the my
if we had if we pulled out of Berlin
leaving a German Force there the
Russians would have gone that day and
taken it
there's a book I haven't covered it on
the podcast yet it's called the donkeys
and it's written by a guy uh that kind
of observed he wasn't in World War one
but he he
observed what the generals did in and
the and the military government
leadership in World War one and he wrote
this book he wrote a long time ago but
it's called the donkeys
and it comes from that quote that
everyone's heard usually they say Lions
led by Lambs or something along that
that's what they would say about the
British or that some German said that
about the British the actual quote was
Lions led by donkeys that's what the
Germans said about the Brits and this
guy wrote this book just talking about
what what is you know what terrible
leadership it was and I don't know I'm
thinking of uh I think of a lot of these
leaders that we have nowadays as being
donkeys especially when you see these
Collective decisions where
it's like everybody knows everybody can
see same thing with Afghanistan there's
not one military person that thought
that was going to go well not none none
and yet the the leadership is executing
on these terrible plans
okay
so you get done with that
um and I think what we I think we
skipped when you were when you were at
the um what 18th Airborne Corps which
kept uh what as a two-star commanding
Fort Benning okay yeah got it yeah and
again that so Benning as Lieutenant
bending as a captain in the careers
course spending as a major and third
range Battalion betting as a batang
commander the tenant Colonel Benning as
a brigade commander and then back for
two stars
so we would tell the housing office
we're coming back so you better take
care of Jesus you better Square these
people away yeah these young soldiers
and their families
um so so
another transformation job you know I
had a lot of them in each of these that
we've talked about transforming the sons
of Iraq to be neighborhood watch instead
of Al Qaeda
um transforming the way soldiers fight
hand to hand that that story about
transforming the sons of Iraq before
they were sons of Iraq they were called
something else and I can't think of it
right now
um but it started out now yeah and and
they had the Marines had said hey these
locals are telling us what's going on
desert protector that's what they called
them and they formed this program called
desert protector and so the first
meeting that we had my information
operations officer had with Sheikh sitar
bazia he said we want to be desert
protectors
and so I got that information and I kind
of started I I tried to figure out what
the desert protectors were desert
protectors had been shut down because
Maliki didn't want a bunch of Sunni
tribal uh Rebels running around that
were armed by Americans so I had to tell
Sheikh bazia hey it it's not desert
protectors anymore it's now called Iraqi
police and we can get you trained and
then he was that sounds good and then
the the one one A.D came in and Colonel
Dean and Sean McFarland they took over
and ran with it and it was great but uh
that the way those things happen was and
then after that came the sons of Iraq
that's when they we actually my my guy
came back with the document
that they had created like the first one
and he he showed it to me I was like
well listen you know we had the
translator go through it and it was
pretty neat to see that stuff unfold
like that yeah it wasn't you know a
common theme on all of this is kind of
the sparkle in the eye of a young
Soldier marine or seal you know then
they realized you know we're doing
something now this is three squared away
um at Fort Benning
uh General Dempsey told me
um I want you he was a tradoc commander
I want you to bring the armor school
from Fort Knox Kentucky to Fort Benning
and change the Infantry Center into the
maneuver center of excellence
they're walking the streets together
anyways tankers and you know artillery
everyone's everyone's doing it
so trying to bring the Infantry and the
armor and the calvary together is the
Shia and the Sunni and the Kurds so I
was trained in many ways
but and and then always having the old
shake so all the retired generals I I'd
go to and I'd say you know retired
four-star armor guy look I didn't make
this stuff up we're bringing the armor
School you need to be you know an
ambassador for a good idea and by the
way doesn't everyone agree that it's
better when we all work together right
right well it doesn't is there anyone
that thinks we're we're gonna go and you
know Branch off and become our own
country no we're going to work together
as United States of America this is what
makes sense we all have supported each
other on the battlefield wouldn't it be
better if we actually train that way but
then rice bowls those silos exactly
exactly and uh the the platform of the
tank
um is really important to the armor guys
and so they will always maneuver jobs
and positions where they can protect
the budget line
I'll get a call on that one that's all
right well I'm a huge supporter of Tanks
myself yeah I actually love tanks and I
love tankers and God bless them you know
we fight as a team you know we deploy as
a team when you need help you shift
assets and they show up and you love
them and you know
stack stack the planes you know to the
Moon over the head of a seal platoon or
a range of platoon and that's all good
you know but that but that that took a
lot of leadership
um two years to
to uh pull actually was about 14 months
of command and then I went back to Rack
as a three star and then I then I came
out of there and took command of all the
Army bases around the world
so I ran 75 cities
in 17 time zones with 123 000 employees
delivering about 300 Services every
single day from Child Development
Centers to at that point 70 golf courses
which I thought I should inspect myself
but also then I realized hey guess what
I have every gym maybe we'll have mats
in most of those gyms that's a good spot
yeah
before we jump into the the gyms and the
Jiu Jitsu and the mats and the gems of
the however many gyms you own now that
you were in this in this position
before we were before we hit record
today and since we were talking about
donkeys uh you mentioned that your
father-in-law actually worked with
Colonel David hackworth in Vietnam
correct give me some give me some
stories come on the the what was the
situation so that they were uh it was
probably
1967 ish
let's just say that and so uh my
father-in-law
then was Lieutenant Colonel promotable
John Hemphill class of 51 West Point and
David hackworth West Side I'm pretty
sure a brigade Commander
and my I'm pretty sure anyways there
were orders that came out of the the
101st division headquarters telling
uh Colonel hackworth to do this or that
or the word came out late or or
helicopters didn't show up but for
whatever reason
he uh Colonel hacker stormed up into
division headquarters a bunch of tents
in the jungle and uh started telling
everyone how that they had really
screwed up and and they're a bunch of
jerks and you know unprofessional and so
my father-in-law stepped in between
Carl hackworth and his his people and
said let's take this outside and talk it
through and
Colonel hackworth allegedly reportedly
said no you know I'm not going anywhere
and so then they they got it on right
there started to find in the tent and
rolled out into the darkness and and but
they remained great friends until my
final law passed away about two years
ago but they they were fond of each
other they knew that each was a warrior
and uh that uh you know you're going to
have disagreements get it on and then
get over it
now when I was kind of uh becoming a a
disciple I guess I don't know if there's
such a thing but it kind of when I
started really getting interested in
hackworth and I was reading his books
and reading them again and starting to
see a lot of good leadership in there
he was absolutely he was absolutely
hated in the entire Navy because he had
done a report he'd done some reporting
on the chief of Naval operations at the
time Admiral borda who was a beloved guy
who is a prior enlisted guy to come up
through the ranks to become the chief of
Naval operations
and Colonel hackworth had done a report
on him that he was wearing some
unauthorized and unearned uh Awards on
his uniform and Admiral bourna killed
himself
so he wasn't popular there he wasn't
popular in the Navy at all the Army I
pretty much got mostly the same thing
from the army that you know the hacker
from hackworth was just bad now recently
I've talked to I actually went out to
West Point and when I was at West Point
they I would I asked the question hey
how does everybody view hackworth now
and they pretty much say I mean a
paraphrase is hackworth was right
what did you did you like you you did
you know about hackworth from your from
your dad or anything like that just a
little just especially when about face
first came out and uh General handed me
the book told me to read it and uh
um and then told the story so but he was
what what did your father-in-law think
of the book
um well he thought it was good enough to
give it to me okay that's a good point
it's interesting because you know you
read the book and you as you read the
book you can go and I I actually had
these thoughts and I thought you know
what was he I mean you know you write a
book about yourself of course you're
going to put yourself in the good light
you're going to make yourself look good
you're going to pull the quotes that
make you look good you're going to tell
the story that makes you look good and I
had a guy named General Jim mukayama on
the podcast who was one of hackworth's
company commanders in Vietnam and I was
really excited I'm like now I'm going to
get the I'm gonna get the real story on
what hackworth was really like what they
really thought of and what was he like
for a commander and you know so I asked
uh General uh General mukayama and he he
couldn't have given hackworth any higher
praise I mean he absolutely just loved
Acworth and he told me that everybody in
the Army knew who he was he said when he
checked in at Fort Lewis
when hackworth checked in uh mukayama
was working like the the the desk the
admin desk the Personnel desk or he was
an aide or something he was but he was
the kind of the young Lieutenant
checking him in
and I said did you know who he was and
he said everybody knew who he was
mystery infantry everybody knew him
everybody knew his reputation so I
thought that that was very reassuring to
me so this is now more reassuring that
uh getting word via your father-in-law
that hackworth was the real deal
both of them
um
you know back in in those days that body
count was was a measure of success or
Effectiveness and so both hackworth and
and
Margie's dad later General Hemphill
um Turned people in who who doctored the
books and uh so they
Margie's dad was was the first West
Point guy of his class to make 06. and
he was the last West Point guy of his
class to make one star
and all the generals that that he
reported had falsified uh the number of
Vietnamese being killed during the South
North Korean maze or Viet Cong you know
he he rendered a report that is not true
and I went all the way back to to the
Pentagon and all those guys that were
three and four five years ahead of him
that sat the promotion boards cut them
out and when the last one retired the
next day he he made the next board here
so I think that's you know that that's
an
the lesson of leadership is is can you
stand strong
when others won't can you stand strong
when it's personally and professionally
not in your interest and and do the
right thing and and we need we need a
lot of that we need more of that and we
need to celebrate it when we see it
do you remember because it's 1989 when
when this book came out do you remember
when it came out was it a big deal in
the Army were people passing it around
were people saying it was a bunch of
crap they were they were yeah they were
lovers and haters 89 I was in uh second
range Battalion out of Fort Lewis my
father-in-law had retired in 85 out in
Fort Lewis and so
um like it or not every Sunday we were
over at their house you know for Sunday
afternoon dinner and and I became I
loved my father-in-law today I liked him
but it would be you know come over have
a beer we're gonna watch football
absolutely mandatory fun love when but
when the book came out that's why it's
so easy for him to say hey read this now
and uh
that there were some that
you know another thing for Our
Generation we sort of looked at
um if the person wasn't charismatic in a
big way we didn't want to hear about
back in Vietnam so in many camps the
book that describes a warrior leading in
time of combat was probably a little bit
uh over overcast or overshaded by the
context of it was Vietnam so we'll we'll
give you guys that that uh opinion was
like hey
Vietnam we we know all about Vietnam was
it hey Vietnam was you were it was a
different different situation that
doesn't convey to what we have to deal
with now a little bit of a little bit of
that that doesn't convey it doesn't
match up but the other was the the
context of arriving in your first units
and your captain screwed up and your
sergeants have two or three DUIs and you
know the the carryovers and then they
start telling you you know you have to
be squared away like we are and you're
looking thinking you know young and full
of life and going
I'm not sure I agree that you're squared
away you know and uh so so then when
we're in the basic course of the campus
course and someone said well back in nam
you're like oh please yeah I kind of
look at you now yeah and then you know
that in time they Sunset and
you know the the new uh non-commissioned
officer the more professional uh on
purpose using those words literal a plan
to make them professional came in we
called the you know the sergeants in
Vietnam shake and bake all right and so
nowadays people don't know what shake
and bake is but back in those days it
was a pouch of of uh breadcrumbs and you
put the chicken in it and you shake it
up and then you bake it and you have
Kentucky Fried Chicken well they've made
sergeants shake and bake in other words
after about a month or two uh in the
combat zone they put pinned rank on them
and said you're now an NCO and many of
them they didn't have basic NCO course
Advanced NCO course you know
um
primary leader development course they
didn't have that non-commissioned
uh Officer school like we do today like
we did in the 90s and and 2000s
so so anyways point is when uh when when
his book came out probably have to be
before like a.m you know I'm not sure of
the lessons
a Vietnam are going to be relative to me
or pertinent when in fact you know
leadership is transcended
yeah and the other thing is it seemed
like like I came in in 1990 1990 it
didn't seem like we were going to have
another big long prolonged War you know
like those we all thought we'd do one
Mission you know do one big mission and
that would be that the big Mish there
was no look and then and then the first
Gulf War was over in 72 hours okay well
that's what war is now you maybe we'll
fight for you know maybe we'll do one
big mission in a 72-hour War but that's
what war is going to be like from now on
it wasn't going to be this 10-year thing
like Vietnam where you got all this
experience and you're going to be out
doing all these operations night after
night after night
and boy were we wrong about that
um
so all right so I just wanted to get
some get your perspective on hackworth I
appreciate that now
you were just saying you took over all
the bases uh in the world that's right
you're the Army basis yeah all the army
bases in the world which means you're in
charge of the golf courses I'm not a
golfer but it means you're in charge of
the gyms
and inside gyms you can put mats now at
this point I think uh 2012 I saw an
article that you got your brown belt
not the jacquire that you know from UFC
out there everybody the old school
jacquire who's a a Brazilian Jiu Jitsu
black belt from the previous generation
on old school I went there and trained
in his school when I went from officer
candidate School in in Pensacola Florida
and I was going to Seal Team two in
Virginia Beach and I stopped in in
Atlanta and trained for seven days just
one trained every day all day that was
into that was in 1998. okay so you're a
brown belt at this time you've been you
kept training Jiu Jitsu which is awesome
and and now you have the opportunity to
start putting some combatives training
areas and all these different gyms so
how was that well
like anything else it would it took you
know one two three cups of tea so go go
to the location meet with the the two
Star General
and and you know where you have your
guys so you already know Sergeant so and
so they're major so-and-so's there
and so you go to the general and say
um resources are tight in the army they
always are but I can square you away and
so here we can we can build a
world-class facility here which gym
would you want to put it in so rather
than saying I own the gym and have the
truck show up in the middle of night
with mats for the program to stay alive
that General needed and his certain
major needed to uh to want it and and
for the most part they did and so we
went to Fort Drum then to Fort Campbell
then to Fort Lewis
and some of them now have huge training
facilities that they spawned off of the
original gym idea and so the the uh the
strategy was
um take away any excuses for people not
training their people and uh oh you know
you know we always got basketball
intramurals
you'll get you'll be okay you're going
to be you'll have enough yeah 12 gyms at
Fort Craig you're going to be okay and
then oh people get hurt no more people
get hurt playing racquetball in Army
facilities than training Jiu Jitsu and
or combatants
and then mostly you know I I just don't
want a generation
uh to be asked by their grandson you
know did you ever get in a fight dad a
Granddad and he's no but I but I can I
can put a PowerPoint presentation
together like he'd never seen you know I
just that's not the more you ethos and
you said it early
if there's a place where the Eternal
Flame of warrior ethos should burn it
should be forward bending in front of
the the the main building there and as
Fort Benning and the Infantry go so goes
the army
and as the Warriors of each service go
still goes to their their Warrior uh
their Warrior ethos
so so uh you know no one likes change
but a baby with a wet diaper right and
so when you when you show up and tell
the guy who's in charge of all the gyms
who works for you that we're going to do
this he says no sir
you know that's Mission money not not
morale money and and you tell them you
know do you think
um taking that stance is worth your job
because I one of my guys said just
unencumbered their future and I said
this program is going to happen so let's
all be
for something that's going to happen and
that's what stamina Crystal told me yeah
we're gonna do this so be forward big
time because you'll love you'll love
your life much more than if you drag
your heels
so that that guy three years later
um was two thumbs up and he had been a
wrestler so he's in the department there
we civilian he'd been a wrestler he was
just reading a
you know he was he wasn't doing what's
right he was doing it right and I said
let's do what's right instead change the
manual I had to do it to to get there if
your MWR manual says the gyms are solely
for the use of you know after our you
know basketball volleyball and
intramurals change it and for use
by you know soldiers in training go for
it too easy yeah exactly and and it
really is impressive the army combatives
they have the combatives tournaments
yeah which are which are pretty awesome
um is that just coming from Matt Larson
did they come up with that idea yeah in
Troy yeah yeah I I have a picture on my
wall in museum of about 28 people were
all in the
army green
Woodland bdus Matson picture chores in
the picture
a young colonel farader's in the picture
that was the first
Army combatives tournament and then and
uh and I I kind of just closed my eyes
once you started talking because just
last week was the 20th okay and I and I
got too busy and I couldn't go down
there they invited me and all that Matt
is the the father of Army combatives and
and I'm The Godfather okay
I was gonna guess grandfather but maybe
that would have been a bit much for you
well no I I take that too
um grandfathers have unconditional love
for their grandkids but
um
when someone messes with the program
then I show I'll show up again and just
go close the door with whoever it is and
say you know you've
if if I say to you you want to choose
you want to go shoot your sniper rifle
you want to go shoot compare it oh yeah
you want to drop a mortar around oh yeah
you know you want to shoot the machine
gun yeah yeah okay you know pull a
lanyard on an artillery piece shot you
want to go down to the mats oh well my
back is you know and I I told I tell the
senior officials just don't say no you
don't have to
you know if you're not into it that's
fine I think you should be into it I
think you should try it enough you know
do Jiu Jitsu or any other martial art
enough that you understand what it is
and if that doesn't move you then then
don't be moved that's fine but but don't
make it you wouldn't make it that
decision on anything else as a leader
but on this one there's so much ego then
uh oh yeah or lack of humility
I came up with a protocol for how long
you need to train your Jitsu for because
I'd get asked this question a lot but by
people that don't really like it
for whatever reason it's sweaty it's hot
their ego's getting crushed and I said
you my protocol now I tell people is you
train Jiu Jitsu until you tap someone
out
and then if you say if you don't if you
get that feeling of tapping someone out
and you don't say yes it's pretty cool
then maybe Jiu Jitsu isn't for you but
you at least need to train that that
long I like it yeah
so then you 2014 you actually get
promoted to black belt once again from
Jaco Ray
uh when you were training when you were
overseas when you were on deployment
were you training did you guys did you
have enough guys to train with yes yeah
you always found people to train yeah
thinking that
um or understanding that I started
training as a full colonel how old were
you when you started training
probably 40
3 44.
check so
I
we took 18th Airborne Court in into Iraq
in 2008.
January 2008 we stayed till June of
roughly June of 2009 15 months
the second plane who had the mats
and and I brought I just sent a picture
to Henner
I'm sorry to hear on and give Valente in
Miami the Volante brothers and uh I
brought them over and they they gave
seminars at 28 different operating bases
yeah and and uh and so over there yes
um when deployed
keep doing it
we built a gym next to the Embassy in
Union three across the street from the
embassy and part of it was probably
something like uh 70 feet by 70 feet of
that beautiful and then someone you know
went to the IG and said that
you know I misused the gym I built it
for my personal you know and it's like
look we built it for everybody and we
want everybody training you know you you
would want a squad leader or a young NCO
was a team of four or five
to come in there three times a week and
and go through situations okay we're in
a room they grab you now what now what
now what so so yeah so I continue to
train and then was
graduated to Black Belt by jockery and
Matt
um awesome yeah and uh is Matt did Matt
get his black belt from chakrai he did
okay yeah
that's awesome yeah
and now 2014 this is what was that was
that your last tour it was yeah I
retired in June of 2014.
and then what'd you do once you retired
um so I went up to uh Fort Lewis took
Margie back to the hometown where her
mom and dad and her four of her sisters
were and I told her when you're sick and
tired of your four sisters we'll go
somewhere else so we were there about
two years and she looked over and said
I'm ready and then Dan was deploying to
uh
and how many kids do you have four yeah
two boys and two girls Megan age 42 Dan
H 40
Patty 38 and uh Mary Whitney about 35
how old are you 66. nice and you still
train I do
yeah Echo has spoken I'm getting better
man I'm getting better all the time you
get on a match is it you know
um do you do what do you do for workout
besides jiu jitsu do you lift weights
every day do you calisthenics every day
do you do nothing at all except Jiu
Jitsu no I'll get about 10 workouts in a
week and uh I stopped running I'm about
to restart but in uh when covet hit we
got locked down into Monterey and and uh
shouldn't too bad
um my uh three of my grandkids were
there and we started just getting a cup
of coffee and walking them and so we
would walk you know eight miles walk out
into the valley and back
um but then I'll do weights do the
Peloton bike
um
I'm not sort of build the quads work in
the quads and lower legs quite a bit
um and then golf I'll play golf uh
and I and I'm I'm in this you know
skills and drills I'm not into score and
you're never going to get me pissed off
on a golf course you know with all the
stuff that we've seen in our life it's
like look it's just you know it's
mechanical you can't hustle you can't
try harder you can't motivate yourself
you gotta strike the ball you know but
now so that's ready yeah
and then and then currently you've got
the national Veterans Memorial and
Museum okay and and tell us how that
came about yeah so when when I retired I
started the federal group and we we
decided that we would help transitioning
veterans help find employment and and
all and like I said in our store now at
the Museum every you know something like
48 different companies
um
all veterans are have their merchandise
and product we have books uh in there we
should take yours as well we have uh
um
and then then when we bring an exhibit
in there so anyways so I set out in 2014
to help I also started Hands-On inspired
leadership which really is using Jiu
Jitsu as a metaphor for life to close
the distance establish the dominant
position and finish and then giving that
to high schoolers did all the Medics and
and nurses in the hospital uh at Fort
Lewis the freshman class at the Citadel
three years in a row and basically
you're you know telling young girls it's
like women empowered you know your body
is your body you can say stop right
there take two steps back you can tell
alcohol stop right there get back we can
defeat suicide we can defeat depression
we can defeat clock
and so I'm still on that mission
we right now I'm working with the
Columbus Police Department to set up a
oil hands-on-inspired leadership with
them because they they do have Jiu Jitsu
instructors but that's the sports side
or the or the I love it side but how do
you decompress someone you know I've got
a picture of uh
ball uh my my executive assistant puts
the rubber band on the next one on the
next one and so it's about size of a
baseball
and I took a picture of it and I said to
someone that's what PTSD is that's what
pts is right there and you got to take
that apart one by one by one until the
tension's gone but you can best do that
through healthy activities through
Sports through Jiu Jitsu through the
connection that comes in the gym when
all those guys that we just walk by you
just feel it right so
um so
um
then I started helping companies if if
you tell someone that you ran all the
army bases around the world you had a 12
billion dollar a year budget he took it
down to nine
that you have more than 200 parachute
jumps and four combat tours
they say you know thanks for your
service you know but you tell them that
those bases you were dispersing the
checks then people would say oh now
you're a consultant so
so Mike ferreter helps companies connect
wherever they need to be connected so
into the military or
um
Army Air Force exchange service
we do that and we do it for the right
reason we do it because there's someone
out there making goodness happen and we
want your grandkids to say Granddad
Whoever thought of helping you out to
get that product and Big Lots is another
another friend of ours
pretty big
um the West Point graduate is their CEO
Bruce Thorne and he wants to help
veterans too so then so I got this call
First
first I went to uh
three things happen Senator Isaac said
and I said I will fix the VA I just
fixed the biggest part of the army and
uh and so I interviewed with the
president so team eight lawyers
and
um The Wall Street Journal announced
that I was a finalist to be the
secretary of the VA and the next day
president Trump went in and said the
secretary will just keep it you're doing
great and the team
so then
um I interviewed to be the president and
CEO of the Wounded Warrior Project and
uh my good friend Mike linnington got
the job he's done a fantastic job
so then I got a call to come and
interview to be the president of the
Citadel which is when you figure out how
I ended up at this little that's kind of
comical to think about that
and then my classmate and friend Marine
different retired four-star Glenn
Walters got that so I turned to Margaret
I said man I'm not too good at getting
job for three
and she said you know we we know we're
unencumbered we're free to do whatever
we want and then I got a call from a
lady in corn ferry in Atlanta
and her secretary said can you take a
call on Friday
with uh with with Jane and I said of
course and uh so then I said hey wait a
minute your your phone your prefix is
706 are you in Atlanta
yeah I said well I'm going to be in
Atlanta on Friday can I just see her
face to face
and she said I said if that's breaking
the rules no problem but yeah come on so
I went in I'm interviewed with this
Headhunter and uh we hit it off pretty
good and when I was leaving she said who
else are you going to see in Atlanta
today I said no one
came up here to see you so have you ever
hired anyone on the phone no so so then
they took me to Columbus Ohio
living in Columbus Georgia and
interviewed me and they said what do you
think of this National Veterans Memorial
Museum or national
vmm.org for for the listeners
and it is John Glenn was the senator the
astronaut the fighter pilot the test
pilot
and he would look down on the old vets
and then he would call the titans of
industry in Columbus Ohio and say that
that is not upfitting it's not good for
for our vets it's an old raggedy looking
thing so they knocked it down and they
built this beautiful
facility and when they walked me in what
year was that built 2017 2016. again it
looks like it's brand new yeah it's
beautiful so I'm the founding CEO and
president of it they said what do you
think you know General Farrer and I and
I said it's insufficient to our need
and they say oh my God we put 62 million
dollars in there what did we forget I
said you forgot that there's veterans in
San Diego there's veterans in Tampa
there's veterans in Fort Lewis
in Iowa and they're not coming to Ohio
so we're going to need so they they said
so so what what what's that's you know
smarty pants what are you going to do so
we'll have virtual tours and we'll have
a veteran or store and we'll bring
product in and help veterans that are
small business owners
I said we'll go to Ohio State University
and we'll have a leader certification
course for veterans and so when when you
get asked that question as a veteran you
don't have any continuing education
what have you been doing tonight and the
answer is yeah Patrols in ramadi that's
what I was doing you know and so we've
run four semesters of leader
certification they get six hours of
Master's credit
um you can take it from right here right
um and so we're growing that program
this is like off the cuff
this you know and you know it depends
nice to meet you anything you want to
say
and then and I told him um
that we would probably have a wellness
and resilience program with things like
Jiu Jitsu and and yoga which we have and
we've had for two years
um and I told them that uh we'd have
young inner city youth especially as
youth ambassadors and we run summer
camps
um on a
you can see it there's a big giant field
right there and uh and so now and and
when we run the summer camp the coach
will be a policeman
another first responder and a veteran
and these kids that are throwing water
bottles at cops and and vilifying cops
and and all this they'll get to know
that these are men and women of
character who give a about people
and our leaders
so
the national Veterans Memorial Museum
one of our mottos is
more than a museum and I'm an Army
Ranger more than a history guy and we
can build teams and then we don't need
to own anything but we started an
employment service now we call a veteran
concierge so we connect
big companies and little companies to
Veterans and we have an I.T solution
that that
um called opline and it'll
um you just fill out a checklist went
you know went to the boot camp when went
to buds went to here deployed here cut
this college this this
I have a driver's license you know I'm a
sniper and then it'll say
um you're fully qualified and here's the
kicker you're fully qualified
um for these 14 jobs and these seven
companies
in these different parts of the of the
nation and so when the Veteran's going
through that now instead of going all
the way through the employment thing and
then they say you're just not a perfect
fit and he's got to start over and start
over so we're we're in our pilot year
probably best way to say it and uh
all of those were the original vision of
what we could do and and much much more
so we're getting after it and you got
your uh bride away from our Four Sisters
I did the bonus program yeah the other
thing that's interesting in that regard
is we bought a house in Ohio in Columbus
Ohio and that is the first house that
I've ever purchased
wow because I've always been on Army
bases or whatever
yeah so life is good
well that does that get us up to speed
is that is that pretty much where we're
at this gets us to today it does and
um
where can people find you
uh that they could find me at
National
vmm.org or M farader at
nationalvm.org or Mike at the fair Rider
group okay and the fair you got the
fair2group.com I'm assuming as well and
then you're on social media I I am I'm
on LinkedIn and Facebook uh Instagram
and and and then the social media of our
museum is I water it's just fantastic
okay what's what's the social media of
the um that's the one I don't have I
have I have you on Instagram at uh Mike
farider
on Twitter Mike underscore ferriter and
I have Facebook at Michael farader
what's the what's the social media of
the national yeah I would go to
nationalvmm.org which would give you the
landing page and you just scroll down
and then just hit it yeah okay awesome
and what do you what do you guys post on
there that on the social media side
our podcasts are on on our Facebook okay
awesome and then uh
one of the one of the things in that
same discussion interview I I said you
know we'll do these podcasts and and in
essence
um we'll have a virtual Museum Hall so
whether it's short stories or uh whether
it's you know 30 minute to 50 minute
um you'll be you can be able to query
and say I'm interested you know
in Vietnam era guys I'm interested in in
board who I'm interested in Lessons
Learned and Leadership and so
so it's like we have 35
000 square feet
of Museum we've got about nearly 4 000
square feet of mats just saying and then
uh but but we can have 350
000 square feet of virtual Museum Hall
yeah you can and we'll never run you
know like
what did I hear 386
yeah this is podcast number 386. I mean
you got you've got your your own uh
you know virtual Museum storytelling uh
opportunity here people can cover
that you can hear hear about hackworth
directly yeah you know it's awesome yeah
it's awesome uh Echo Charles any
questions yeah what are the rules for
that combative tournament
because I mean how do they differ from
like you know your general Jiu Jitsu
tournament rules yeah the the beginning
um
so I think they're three levels now one
is one is it's straight commanders
they're they're wearing uh the Army
battle dress uniform or fatigues
level two as you Advanced and uh kicking
and striking the Torso
and then in the finals kicking and
striking
so the first level is essentially like
General Jiu Jitsu rules you got points
for you know passing guard site and all
that kind of stuff and then uh only if
you don't tap them yes yes of course of
course that's submission and then you go
essentially to like a pancreation
scenario yeah right no no headstray and
then to MMA essentially okay right on
yeah yeah yeah that's legit right there
they just had like I said they just had
the the tournament and I didn't get to
go but all of the beginners all of the
founders were there they're all older
men beards and their bellies do they do
they escalate through all the bases and
have like a all-army combatives
tournament that thing needs to be
televised I think Jocko fuel needs to
sponsor that yeah that'd be I see them
everyone yeah
what do you see them on YouTube or
something yeah on YouTube or something
they're not on like a big channel it's
not like the event show it's like a clip
like someone recorded it or something
like that yeah they were ready this year
if we had this four months ago if a few
hours
well next year we'll be doing it and
yeah Tim Kennedy who's a friend of mine
and how would you like to be like an
army dude and you show up and you Tim
you have to fight Tim Kennedy
an actual UFC dude you know like you're
like man I think we got our blue belt
the same day oh you and Tim from a horse
yeah oh right on and Tim was at Fort
bragging with the special force of guys
and I would go in there once while and I
see you so if if I'm holding you like
this then what
yeah that works okay yeah
that's awesome uh now uh anything else
no that's it thank you great to meet you
thank you my pleasure General any any
closing thoughts
well I I just appreciate
um the chance to be here I'm I'm really
humbled to to be sitting with you
um I hope that that any message that I
send out there to someone can help
somebody secondly
um so there's a guy in Columbus Ohio
named Zach he said if I hit let Zach sit
there he would let me have food and beer
at his dad's restaurant for the rest of
my life
but uh you should have brought him down
that's cool well send him out to visit
something did he train Jiu Jitsu no okay
we'll send him out to visit he can train
some Jujitsu okay we'll make it happen
then he that way you can eat for free
there we go I gotta take care of the
general to the rest of uh the audience
there's a friend out there that needs to
hear from you so give a call send a text
check on your battle buddy your shipmate
your your fellow team member check on
somebody because you don't know if
that's the one that's going to make a
difference sometimes they just come in
and they'll start working out again and
all that other times they say he had a
gun I'm right here in front of me so we
can all make a difference in that stuff
and then
um if I could get you to
really honored to meet you uh for the
person and people that you guys are and
the difference that you make for a lot
of people
well uh obviously thanks for joining us
today thanks for sharing your
experiences and your lesson learned over
your career of 35 years and
um more important thanks for your
service in those 35 years in in Somalia
in Iraq countless other places around
the world uh static line jumping into
God knows where to do God knows what
uh and thank you for what you are
continuing to do today to
preserve and memorialize our veterans
and our history
uh it is much appreciated thank you sir
all right sounds good thank you
and with that General Mike farider has
left the building
and we just walked out he was definitely
excited about the Jiu Jitsu mats yeah
he's definitely into Jiu Jitsu and jiu
jitsu
helping in all aspects of life if you're
not trained in jiu jitsu
go change your Jitsu yeah I think it's
pretty straightforward
yeah I think it's pretty straightforward
it's a good way to
add
value and that's not a popular that's
not something I like to say yeah because
you know why because in the military
that turns into a thing like all right
we're really going to add value here
right so it's a corporate buzzword right
and it's in the military as a corporate
in the military as a buzzword add value
over value added either one of those two
we could go either direction
but Jiu Jitsu is is going to add value
to every part of your life now I would
say unfortunately or fortunately it is
secondary to what you claimed on one of
our early podcast earliest podcasts that
physical exercise is across the board
gonna help out every aspect of your life
yeah I would prioritize that as number
one
from physical activities I would put Jiu
Jitsu as number two that's where I'm
putting it I agree yeah so and it was
interesting that uh recently I forget
what
I even forget what you said but
it was along the lines oh you said
something along the lines of uh I was
talking about lifting weights we were
talking about lifting weights how that
that'll help every aspect of your life
right exercise whatever we'll just say
lifting weights and then you were like
well
even though you don't use it all the
time because it's not like every day
you're gonna be like you know power
lifting something something along those
lines he said
and I remember thinking later on I was
like wait a second that's because that's
not really the the benefits of the
weightlifting
benefits of the weightlifting is let's
say you're like strong like
notably strong in all lifts and all
things or whatever
it does translate to Everyday stuff
like if your chain you ever change one
of those water bottles those five gallon
water bottles in the cooler that's way
easier when you're strong for sure I'm
saying so there's tons of little things
that you can do day to day I thought
what you were gonna say I thought you're
gonna say something that was meaningful
that is beautiful it is meant something
to people I thought you'd say like hey
when you lift every day it creates
discipline in your life it makes you
overcome a challenge every day it makes
you mentally tired so you just go down
there I think you know you're gonna talk
about five gallon water bottles but
that's true that's it's all real it's
all part of it that's what I'm saying
that's how beneficial it is because we
can go deep like you or just go not so
deep like me and everywhere in between
and boom the lifting is gonna you know
it's gonna add value so jiu jitsu
it's going to help you with your
confidence I mean look the physical
things help you to be more flexible
you're going to get good cardio you're
going to get good grip strength strength
in general you're gonna get the
appropriate reception is going to be
improved so there's a bunch of physical
things that you're gonna get but man the
mental aspect the release of aggression
the confidence built like you want a kid
you got a kid that lacks confidence put
them in Jiu Jitsu yeah put them in Jiu
Jitsu you you have a
22 year old that lacks confidence get
him in a jiu jitsu yeah you've got a 38
year old that lacks confidence get him
in a jiu jitsu so it's going to be
beneficial in so many different and yes
you know what else that gives you gives
you discipline gives you the power to
overcome gives you the power to fight
through things gives you a sense of
community introduces you to new people
there's all kinds of beneficial things
when it comes to Jitsu is it secondary
to to
health and fitness strength training
cardiovascular training Mobility
training it's secondary to those things
it's also complementary yeah like
there's some people wait do you lift and
Jujitsu on the same day everyone's well
yeah is that just but it's not it's not
planned it's no if you if you set up
your perfect schedule would you do both
things on the same day one day yeah one
day a week yeah one day a week would
have two days yes but only one day a
week okay they're essentially Jiu Jitsu
and Fitness we'll talk about a workout
or whatever would overlap on one day
okay only one day
but they are complementary
you can do that you can do one Jiu Jitsu
one day lift or work out the next stage
Jiu Jitsu the next day workout the next
day you could do that or you could do
like I do I do Jiu-Jitsu and workout the
same day all the time I do that well let
me put it this way every time I train
Jiu Jitsu I lifted that day so we're
batting a hundred percent yeah man and
you know some days I went for a run as
well some days I went for a surf as well
in fact most days I went for a run as
well so we got into controversy about
this remember
on on uh on more plates more days oh
yeah the steroids yeah that's one of the
things that that he said which I was my
fault because I said yeah I'll work out
three or four times a day to me that was
like oh lift Jiu Jitsu run surf
this isn't me going in and doing you
know super squats right and so he took
that as oh if this guy's lifting four to
three to four times a day he's he's
doing steroids right so my fault for not
clarifying that but
I do do that I do that as often as I can
as a matter of fact now am I tired when
I get done that dude I was tired we got
home from training on Sunday
this Sunday I was training you you you
weren't there actually no no and you
weren't there on Saturday either no no I
never I never go on Saturday I don't
think I've ever been there Saturday okay
so I go on Saturday all the time right
off it's been awesome I was tired on
Saturday no no sorry on Sunday that's
the good training yeah you get it out
man you get you leave nothing on the map
that's good training yeah feeling good
about that but it doesn't inhibit me
I might feel a little bit tight but I'll
still serve I'll still go for whatever
y'all still go for a run I'll still do
other stuff I won't let it stop me yeah
is what I'm saying hard training is not
going to stop me from doing more
training I might not be the the best run
I've ever done yeah but I'm gonna get it
get some get some if you know what I'm
saying so
let's do Jiu Jitsu that's my that's my
recommendation workout do Jiu Jitsu I
mean look at the look at the general
here 66 years old right you know she's
still trading yeah started at 43. he
said 43. so that's one of those men 43
that was like a couple years ago for me
just starting and has a black belt by
the way yeah so it's like you know those
things come on let's face it that's a
common question where it's like hey I'm
40. is it too late for me to start
because a lot of times you see these
tournaments and these guys you know you
see Gordon Ryan you know excelling in
Jiu Jitsu and all these other guys where
you look at them you're like bro I'm 40.
right now that's not me no that's
somebody else you know kind of thing but
it's right it's not necessarily like
that you know even actually as a
competitor you can still start at 40. oh
yeah for sure you can do the Masters
yeah the divisions yeah they got weight
uh weight and age divisions and belt
divisions across the board so let's go
train some Jujitsu train jiu jitsu
guess what I'm gonna need some fuel you
know what you're gonna need during
Warfare yeah for a hundred percent yeah
that's gonna help the go get some joint
Warfare from jockoffuel.com get some get
some drinks get yourself some ah man
I went two I went two on the discipline
girl get yourself some discipline go get
yourself some Mulk you're post training
Mulk maybe that's why you can just keep
getting after it you got that Mulk
hitter yeah get that protein going
that's all good for you uh you know we
got hydration coming yep I'm drinking
one right now it's right over here yeah
it's
freaking awesome electrolyte beverage
yeah it's so good yeah so good uh you
know once again
natural that's that's what we're doing
we're making it literally good for you
so we got that coming online
um if you want this stuff check out taco
fuel.com or go to Wawa go to Vitamin
Shop go to the military commissaries and
I just got word today from Joe Moss you
know Joe Moss yeah that's got word from
Joe Moss where
pending going into the military
exchanges so those of you in the
military know what I'm talking about
we're in Hannaford's we're in dash doors
we're in Wake from ShopRite HEB
down in Tejas by the way if you're in
Texas your your support is appreciated
of the cause
at HEB HEB is like
is these this is our front lines yeah so
when you're out there in HEB we
appreciate your support on the front
lines of the battle we're in Meyer we're
in Harris Teeter just rolled into Harris
Teeter so you got a Harris Teeter by you
check that out Lifetime Fitness big gyms
you've been to a Lifetime Fitness before
yes they're big yeah
um go they got they got the drinks
they got the supplements so go check
that out jacofuel.com make yourself
better also origin USA American made
they started with the geese you know
we're doing Jiu Jitsu here when you
start Jiu Jitsu if you haven't already
you're gonna need a ghee you want to
make sure it's American-made probably
the best quality ghee no matter who made
it
yep yep you know okay you just mentioned
American made
I'm starting to get more and more fired
up because I see other companies out
there and what pisses me off is not that
the other companies are out there that
doesn't make me mad
it doesn't make me mad that they're out
there it makes me mad when they
they're they they are sending a virtuous
message about themselves about their
company and how they're doing good and
they're actually lying
they're actually lying about this
they're not doing good they're they're
they're they have slave labor for one
thing instantly if you have slave labor
you're done you're not doing anything
good you can't do anything virtuous hey
if you want to go and you want to make
your stuff in China and you want to sell
it here you want to keep your mouth shut
and make money okay
you're bad but I have beef with you but
it's a contained beef
when you start telling
people about how virtuous you are when
you are literally have slave labor and
you're dumping chemicals into the into
the water and you're pouring chemicals
into the air that's what you're doing
and then you're talking to the American
people as if you're virtuous you're a
liar you're a scum
so don't be a part of that
don't be a part of that
get American made
to get American made I don't care who it
is look look Origins American made good
you can get that you need that cool but
whatever you're getting get yourself
something that's American made
and especially this is especially true
with clothing
especially true with clothing because
those are sweat shops over there
so go to originusa.com we're taking care
of the workers we're taking care of the
environment and we're taking care of you
because we're giving you the best damn
genes the best ghee the best hoodie the
best T-shirt we're giving you the best
and you don't have to have the karma
of slavery
and and ecological disaster on your soul
it's freaking terrible
originusa.com go get it get it
yeah those jeans are uh
extra legit black jeans available right
now yep Delta 68. so the total what are
the what are the different models of the
genes I know the Delta 68 the many
washes of course then there's the and
then there's a factory factory yep yeah
and that's more like the thicker one
right not as stretchy still a little bit
stretchy oh it's definitely stretchy but
more heavy yes it's just thicker yeah
like if you're in if you're in Minnesota
yeah you might want those Factory jeans
wintertime
if you're in
Montana winter time you want those
Factory jeans even though I'll be honest
with you I wear the Delta jeans I wear
Delta 68s year round yeah but my legs
don't if your legs ever get cold no I'm
surprised your legs don't get a little
chilly well I mean they're kind of
skinny
they have the capability to get cold yes
thank you for asking to your knees
generally speaking we're pretty warm
over here okay generally speaking thank
you the Jocko for asking all right but
yeah the Delta 68 oh yeah all year all
year all day that that's my my um what
do you call my
my Formal Wear check yeah me too all
right also Dragon store called Jaco
store if you want to represent on the
path discipline equals freedom because
it does by the way
the idea of good
right good something if you if you're
faced with something bad there's some
good to come from it you want to
represent bro I'm telling you shirts
hats hoodies whatever you need
jockostore.com also we have a
it's called the short Locker
subscription scenario get a new shirt
every month different designs creative
who will say did you see Leif and Dave
on the airplane together yeah
uh Dave wrote planned or not what do you
think I don't think it was playing I
don't think it was planned either
because I can't really see them like
calling each other off be like hey I'm
gonna wear the freaking again shirt you
know so yeah not planned uh that's a
good shirt though so and I understand
that kind of coincidence and that's not
even that much of coincidence because
it's like hey if you're gonna choose one
I could see why someone would choose
that one we got two people doing it so I
get it that was the January shirt for
2022.
again yeah
Jack so do you understand the layer
behind that right oh yeah you know new
year new me nope we're gonna do the same
good stuff we've been doing again
and actually I got it from you
all right there you go no that's because
sometimes I like wake up in the morning
you know and I'm posting yeah and guess
what I'm doing
everything that I did yesterday again
again I'm getting up early again you're
going to work out again that's what's
happening again I swear I got it so
there you go get yourself some of that
uh Jocko store.com go to subscribe to
this podcast subscribe to the Jocko
underground subscribe to the YouTube
page
the origin USA YouTube page the Jocko
fuel YouTube page the echelon front
YouTube page go check those things out
we got some information on there for you
check out flipsidecanvas.com Dakota
Meyer
badass
yeah he's badass he's a Marine he's just
a guy that can make things happen and he
makes things for your wall too that you
can hang on your wall flipsidecampus.com
check that out we got a bunch of books
written a bunch of books you know what
they are if you don't have them go get
them if you get and listen
the most critical of these look you're
you're 38 years old or you're 42 years
old and you want to get
you want to get leadership strategy and
tactics and become better yourself cool
but more important actually if you know
a kid any kid in your neighborhood the
kid across the street he seems to be
freaking constantly like sitting out in
the yard not doing anything maybe he's
digging the holes for no reason you know
Hawking rocks at things no Direction
get that kid the way of the warrior kid
books get them all five just literally
get them and bring him over to that kid
oh it's a girl no it doesn't matter girl
boy it doesn't matter so many girls read
way the warrior kid doesn't matter no
Factor
and then you know what go to Home Depot
and spend 12 on a piece of pipe and hang
it from a tree in their yard so they can
start doing pull-ups
and then just watch their entire life
get better change the trajectory of
their life
way the warrior kid go get it also got
Mike in the dragons
so that's what you need for kids we
talked about hackers today I wrote the
forward to the re-release of David
hackworth's book about face go pick that
thing up
says it's a 800 page leadership lesson
it wasn't written for the leadership
just written about a dude's life
but when you read it from a leadership
perspective you're going to see what's
in there power
so check that one out also we have
Echelon front which is leadership
consultancy where we solve problems
through leadership we have
echelonfront.com that's where you get
those leadership Solutions we have Live
Events we have online events the Online
Academy is called is at extreme
ownership.com
it's called The Academy extreme
ownership Academy go to extreme
ownership.com if you want to learn the
magic
the magic we talk about Jiu Jitsu like
it's magic guess what else is Magic
knowing how to communicate with other
people
knowing how to interact with other
people that's Magic
so learn it you don't know it just like
you don't know if you don't if you know
Jiu Jitsu cool you know what a power it
is if you don't know what Jiu Jitsu is
and you've ever rolled to somebody you
realize that you get destroyed
I'm telling you right now this is that
is one aspect
of life is being able to fight there's
another aspect of life it's called being
able to interact with other people and
it's magic if you know how to do it
and if you don't know what I'm talking
about right now
if you don't understand what I'm saying
right now you should go to extreme
ownership.com right now and you should
check out one of the free classes and
see go oh that makes sense and then you
go try it and it works
so check that out
and if you want to help
service members active and retired you
want to help their families gold star
families check out Markley's mom mama
Lee she's got a charity organization and
if you want to donate or you want to get
involved go to America's Mighty Warriors
dot org
and also don't forget about Micah Fink
who is I guess last report is wearing a
bare skin
and he is scaling a 14 000 foot
Mountain
in the Rockies
with no water
and he's helping other veterans do that
kind of stuff Heroes and horses.org
Someday I'm gonna go with there when I'm
older I'm gonna do do that whatever it
is 45 Day program learn how to ride a
horse go out in the mountains sit in
cold water
he you know bear or whatever they're
eating yeah you know how to ride a horse
no no a little bit no no not at all I've
ridden a horse up at we have a thing
called the council at Echelon front and
it's up at an off-site location where we
have horses so they put me on what's
called a trail horse do you know where
Trail horses Trail horse is just an old
horse that just walks on it it doesn't
it knows exactly what to do yeah yeah
it's like uh I'm trying to think if
another situation like this it's just a
horse that's gonna kind of be compliant
and it knows just to walk on the trail
yeah it's called the trail horse okay
it's not you're not really riding you're
not riding a horse you're on the horse
and it's walking but you you're hitching
around you're kind of you're kind of
just there okay yeah and it's well Tamed
um but yeah I I so I don't know how to
ride a horse now I've been on a horse
but I don't know how to ride one very
well at all like I know if you pull the
rain this way you pull the rain that way
I know how to stop it in emergency yeah
yeah but right now I would just be
empathetic I'm with you now Iris you
know Iris Gardner yeah oh yeah she was
she's like uh she was a horse Wrangler
my wife too yeah my wife's uh grew up on
horses yeah so she'll just jump on a
horse and jump over stuff and run gallop
and do all this other stuff you know
she's like a cowgirl yeah
in a sense and Miranda Iris yeah she's
from England so is that a cowgirl from
England I don't know what do you call
girl from England
English British cowgirl I don't know we
have to we have to check with the check
with my wife okay I don't think so
though I think Cowboys are I think they
might be American no but there's Cowboys
in like South America too there's like
cowboys in Mexico there's Cowboys and
like down in South America well in
Hawaii because I think there's also in
like in New Zealand and stuff oh fro
yeah maybe so anybody that's basically a
Rancher yeah yeah I guess so in Hawaii
they call them paniolos
are they wearing cowboy hats yes see
there you go and cowboy boots you know
how to lasso and do the whole gig yeah
yeah in fact they have like shows and
stuff too it's pretty cool yeah it's
impressive it's pretty cool like I said
at some point when I have time I'm gonna
go get with Micah Fink and I'm gonna
learn all this stuff Micah Fink did it
yeah he's That Grew he grew up in what
New York and Long Island or something
there you go Micah thinking and he's
just like no I'm gonna actually be a
cowboy in the wilderness in the
wilderness and he straight up is so good
on you there you go
um
if you want to connect with us first of
all with uh General farader you can go
to thefaradergroup.com you can go to
National vmm.org
and then there you can find the the
social media for the national uh
Veterans Memorial Museum
you can also find him on Mike farader on
Instagram Mike underscore Fair on
Twitter and Michael farader on Facebook
and Echo and I are also on the social
media
reluctantly kind of
a little bit
we're there look we're not trying to
waste your brain cells we're trying to
connect maybe you got a question maybe
you want to maybe you want to see what's
happening you can go on there I'm just
saying that there's an algorithm on
there and and I hate to tell you this
there's a decent chance the algorithm is
stronger than you are there's a decent
chance that the algorithm is stronger
than you are don't let it be it's not
it's not because it's more physically
powerful
it's because you're allowing it to be
stronger than you and I'm just saying
don't don't allow the algorithm to be
stronger than your willpower it's a bad
move
and it will make the rest of your life
worse
it will make the rest of your life worse
so don't let that happen and thanks
again to General Mike farider thank you
for your service thank you for your
sacrifice thank you for the lessons that
you passed on to us today
thank you for spreading the word of
jujitsu and starting combatives in the
army
it's awesome
one man a lot of impact and also thanks
to the rest of our Warriors out there in
the military
who are making sacrifices right now
so that we can remain free
also thanks to our police law
enforcement firefighters paramedics
emt's dispatchers correctional officers
border patrol Secret Service and all
First Responders
thank you for what you do every day and
the sacrifices that you make every day
so that we can be safe here and to
everyone else out there let's think
about
let's think about those attributes
that a warrior is supposed to have from
the army combatives manual
here's something to think about personal
courage self-confidence self-discipline
what's interesting about those
attributes
is there not
inherited
they're not passed down in your genes
you don't get personal courage from your
mom and dad you don't get
self-confidence from your genetic gene
pool
and you damn sure don't get
self-discipline in your bloodstream
these are choices that you make
you choose to be courageous you choose
to have confidence
and most important you choose you make
the choice
[Music]
to be disciplined to have
self-discipline
so make the right choice
by getting up every day
and getting after it
and I think that's all we've got for
tonight so until next time this is Echo
and Jocko
out